Rồi. Ok các bạn, buổi tuần trước chúng
ta đang dừng lại cái đoạn chúng ta nói
về cái mối quan hệ tuyến tính đúng
không? Chúng ta nói về chúng ta nói về
coreloration đúng không? Tương quan.
Chúng ta nói về colinearity là đa cộng
tuyến đúng không? Tóm lại là gì? Thì tóm
lại là cái mối quan hệ tuyến tính mà tồn
tại giữa một hoặc là một vài các cái
feature với cả cái target ấy là cái điều
rất là tốt. Tại vì trong trường hợp như
vậy chúng ta có thể chọn những cái mô
hình đơn giản, những cái mô hình tuyến
tính, những cái mô hình mà nó khai thác
tốt cái mối quan hệ tuyến tính, mối quan
hệ bậc một giữa input với cả output.
Thế còn cái mối quan hệ thế còn cái mối
quan hệ tuyến tính giữa các cái feature
với nhau ấy là cái điều mà chúng ta
không mong muốn. Tại vì sao? Tại vì là
nếu mà giữa các cái feature với nhau mà
có mối quan hệ đang có cái mối quan hệ
tuyến tính như vậy thì nó sẽ khiến cho
cái việc là thứ nhất là khi chúng ta sử
dụng những cái mô hình tuyến tính nó sẽ
gây ra hiện tượng là nó dư thừa. Đáng
nhẽ là tôi chỉ cần một feature tôi có
thể làm được cái điều đấy rồi tôi biệt
lại có hai ba feature thì nó sẽ khiến
cho mình nó tướng nhiều tài nguyên hơn
để nó chạy đúng không?
Và thứ hai nữa là gì? Nó sẽ khiến cho
cái việc là chúng ta khó có thể chúng ta
đánh giá được cái tầm quan trọng của
từng feature. Tại vì bây giờ khi mà
giống như kiểu các bạn làm nhóm mà hai
ba người cùng làm một cái tas chẳng hạn
đúng không? Thì bây giờ cái tas này nó
có tốt hay là tồi thì tôi cũng không
biết là tốt thì tốt do ông nào mà tồi
thì tồi do ông nào đúng không? Đấy đấy
là cái nội dung chúng ta đang dừng lại
buổi lần trước.
Thì hôm nay chúng ta sẽ sang một cái nội
dung mới quay cho sang cái phần mới.
Phần này nó sẽ dễ hơn. Phần này nó sẽ dễ
hơn. Cái phần này là cái phần mà nó liên
quan đến riêng bài toán phân loại, bài
toán classification.
Ờ cái buổi trước mình đã nói các bạn
rồi, lúc chúng ta nói về các cái magri
dành cho bài toán phân loại ấy đúng
không? Thì mình có nói với các bạn là
gì? Đó là khi mà các bạn đi làm thực tế
thì gần như là sẽ không bao giờ các bạn
sẽ được gặp một cái bộ dữ liệu cân bằng
dành cho bài toán phân loại á đúng
không? Gần như các bạn sẽ không bao giờ
các bạn gặp một cái bộ rượu nào mà nó
cân bằng đâu. Thông thường rượu bạn nó
sẽ rất là mất cân bằng. Tức là gì? Tức
là sẽ có những sẽ có một cái class này
nó có rất là nhiều sample trong khi một
hoặc là những cái class khác sẽ có rất
là ít sample. Đấy, thông thường nó sẽ là
như vậy đúng không? Còn cái việc mà các
bạn trong thực tế mà các bạn gặp những
cái bài toán thực tế mà có cái rượu cân
bằng đi gần như là các bạn sẽ không gặp
bao giờ cả. Thế thì ờ máy móc nó cũng
giống như con người chúng ta. Cái gì mà
chúng ta gặp nhiều, chúng ta làm nhiều
thì chúng ta sẽ làm tốt. Và cái gì mà
chúng ta gặp ít, chúng ta làm ít thì
chúng ta sẽ làm không tốt thôi. Đúng
không? Ví dụ như là ờ hồi ngày xưa các
bạn, hồi ngày xưa các bạn học lớp 12,
các bạn học toán đúng không? Toán thì có
những cái dạng có những cái dạng toán mà
các bạn gặp rất là nhiều. Ví dụ như là
khảo sát hàm số này đúng không? đạo hàm
này, tích phân này, hình không gian này,
lượng giác này, rồi số phức đúng mà các
bạn gặp rất là nhiều thì các bạn sẽ các
bạn sẽ hay làm đúng, các bạn sẽ hay làm
tốt đúng không? Thế còn có cái dạng toán
nào mà các bạn ít gặp thì các bạn sẽ khả
năng cao là các bạn sẽ làm sai đúng
không? Lớp 12 thì các bạn có cái dạng
toán gì mà các bạn ít gặp các bạn nhỉ?
Cấp 3 có cái dạng toán gì mà ít gặp các
bạn?
Cấp 3 các bạn thấy có toán gì các bạn ít
gặp?
Những cái gặp nhiều thì mình sẽ hay làm
đúng đúng không? Cái gì mà ít gặp ví dụ
như là mình không biết thời các bạn nhưế
nào cái thời ngày xưa của mình nó có cái
thời ngày xưa của mình thi vẫn còn thi
tự luận ấy là không phải trắc nghiệm như
bây giờ đâu. Ngày xưa thi tự luận nên nó
có một cái dạng bài rất là khó mà thường
chỉ các bạn nào các bạn học chuyên các
bạn mới làm được thôi. Còn các bạn học
chương trình thường như mình thường là
chả ai làm được cả. Đó là bài liên quan
đến bất thẳng thức. Bất đẳng thức chứng
minh cái vế này lớn hơn vế kia và tìm
tìm cực trị các thứ. Cái đấy thì bài
toán rất là khó. Thì cái đấy mình ít
gặp. ít khi gặp thì mình sẽ khả năng cao
là mình sẽ không làm được. Thì đây nó y
chang như vậy đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn
muốn sử dụng cái mô hình để dự đoán xem
người ta có bị ung thư hay không. Nhưng
mà hầu hết những cái dữ liệu các bạn đưa
vào mô hình toàn là dữ liệu người khỏe
mạnh cả. Rất là ít người bị ung thư đúng
không? Thì cái gì mà ít gặp thì mô hình
khả năng cao nó sẽ không làm được đúng
không? Thế mà nhưng mà thông thường
thông thường ấy là gì? Là khi mà chúng
ta có những bộ rượu mất cân bằng như vậy
ấ thì nhưng mà cái vấn đề là thông
thường chúng ta lại hay đặt cái sự quan
tâm hay đặt cái sự chú ý vào cái class
thiểu số. Tức là ông nào cái ông ít
sample cái ông các bạn quan tâm đúng
không? Ví dụ là người bị Covid, người bị
ung thư, người bị tiểu đường làm sao đấy
hoặc là cái email spam đúng không? Tức
là thường chúng ta lại hay quan tâm và
những cái nó có ít sample.
Thì bây giờ ấy tôi muốn làm sao tôi có
thể tăng cái khả năng dự đoán của mô
hình cho những cái class thiểu số như
vậy. Tôi muốn cái class thiểu số của tôi
nó phải dự đoán tốt hơn thì tôi làm thế
nào? Thì bây giờ tôi phải làm cho cái
rượu tôi nó
đỡ bị mất cân bằng hơn. Nó đỡ biết mất
cân bằng hơn. Thì đỡ mất cân bằng thì
làm nào? Thì các bạn nhìn ví dụ ở đây
các bạn thấy ở giữa đây đúng không? Ở
giữa các bạn có cái bộ rượu gốc của
chúng ta đúng không? Bộ rượu gốc thì ở
đây các bạn thấy có một cái class nó
nhiều simple hơn. Thật ra cái hình này
nó vẫn không giống thật đâu. Trong thực
tế như này thì vẫn là vẫn là nhẹ. Trong
thực tế thì khi mà rượu mất cân bằng ấy
các bạn sẽ thấy là có những class nó
phải gấp gấp cả chục cho đến gấp cả trăm
lần số lượng sample với cái với những
cái class kia đúng không? Thì ví dụ đây
các bạn sẽ có hai class ở đây đúng
không? Mình gọi một class có nhiều
sample mình gọi là class đa số.
Majority class. Cái class còn lại thì
mình gọi là class thiểu số. Minority
class.
Được chưa? Một ông major, majority ông
minority. Thế bây giờ tôi muốn làm cho
rượu tôi đỡ mất cân bằng thì tôi sẽ có
hai cách cơ bản. Một là bây giờ cái
class nào mà là class đa số thì tôi sẽ
bỏ bớ sle của nó đi. Thì người ta gọi
đây là under sampling. Và hai là ngược
lại gì? Là việc cái tiểu số tôi sẽ tăng
số lượng sample của nó lên thì người ta
gọi là over sampling. Được chưa?
NH có hai kỹ thuật cơ bản như vậy. Hoặc
là người ta có thể kết hợp cả hai được
chưa? Hoặc là người ta kết hợp cả hai
thế đúng không? Tôi làm như vậy để làm
gì? Để tôi có thể giúp cho mô hình tôi
nó tiếp xúc với cái lá tiểu số nó thường
xuyên hơn đúng không? Các bạn tăng số
lượng semble của các kiểu số thì nó cũng
giúp cho mình tiếp xúc với cái lá tiểu
số thường xuyên hơn. Mà các bạn làm giảm
số lượng sle của các l đa số thì nó cũng
giúp cho mình nó tiếp nó tiếp xúc với
cái lá thiểu số thường xuyên hơn. Tại vì
bây giờ cái ông đa số ít gặp đi thì tôi
sẽ có thời gian tôi lo cho ông kia đúng
không? Đây là hai kỹ thuật cơ bản. Đây
là tên của hai cái họ kỹ thuật. Thế còn
cụ thể thì nó trong mỗi một họ kỹ thuật
này nó sẽ có nhiều những kỹ thuật con ở
ở bên trong. Tức là underlinking nó sẽ
có nhiều kiểu mà overling nó cũng sẽ có
nhiều kiểu.
Được chưa? Và các bạn chú ý này, có một
cái có một cái mà rất nhiều tài liệu
người ta dùng mà người ta không có giải
thích và nó khiến cho người học rất dễ
bị sai. Tức là gì? Cái thuật ngữ của cái
thứ mình vừa nói ấy gọi là balance data
đúng không? Balance data là cân bằng dữ
liệu. Nhưng trong thực tế, trong hầu hết
các cái trường hợp cái mục tiêu mà chúng
ta nhắm đến ấy không phải là để cho dữ
liệu của các cái class số lượng sample
nó bằng nhau chẵn chẩn chặn. Không phải
như vậy mà cái mục đích của chúng ta là
gì? Là chỉ chúng ta muốn làm sao để cho
rượu chúng ta nó đỡ mất cân bằng hơn
thôi. Nó đỡ mất cân bằng hơn thôi. Ví dụ
lúc ban đầu cái tỉ lệ giữa class đa số
với với class tiểu số nó là 1 chia 50.
Tức là gì? Cứ một ông thuộc cái lá tiểu
số các bạn mới cứ cứ cứ 50 ông của cái
lá đá đa số các bạn mới có cứ một ông
của lá tiểu số thì tỉ lệ 1/50 nó lệch
quá đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi chỉ làm
sao tôi đưa nó về là 1/5 hoặc là 1/10
thôi nó cũng rất là tốt rồi chứ còn cái
việc mà đưa số lượng sample của class nó
phải bằng nhau chẵn chặn ấy thông thường
thì nó sẽ không tốt. Tại vì sao? Các bạn
có nhớ là cái hôm mà chúng ta
cái hôm chúng ta học về cái việc chúng
ta phân chia dữ liệu ấy đúng không?
Chúng ta có dữ liệu chúng ta chia thành
bộ train, bộ va với bộ test ấy. Đây này.
Đây này. Các bạn nhớ không? Cái hôm
chúng ta nói về chúng ta phân chia dữ
liệu này ấ mình có nói với các bạn là
gì? Là để cho quá trình huấn luyện nó
hiệu quả ấy chúng ta phải đảm bảo cái
gì? Cái phân bố của dữ liệu hay là cái
distribution đúng cái distribution phân
bố của dữ liệu ở bộ train, bộ va, bộ
test nó phải tương đương nhau. Tức là
gì? Ví dụ trong bộ ví dụ là bộ rượu các
bạn có hai class đi đúng không? Thì
chúng ta phải làm sao để cái tỉ lệ của
hai class này [âm nhạc] trong bộ train,
bộ va, bộ test thì nó tương đương nhau
thì lúc đấy học nó mới hiệu quả. Thế
nhưng mà khi mà các bạn thực hiện cái
việc các bạn cân bằng dữ liệu là các bạn
đã thay đổi cái distribution, thay đổi
cái phân bố rồi đúng không? Thế nhưng mà
đấy là cái thứ chúng ta phải chấp nhận.
Tại vì nếu chúng ta cứ để nguyên cái
distribution này thì cái class số lượng
class sample này rất là ít. Số lượng
sample của class thiểu số rất là ít đúng
không? Chúng ta sẽ buộc phải cân bằng,
chúng ta buộc phải làm sao chúng ta thay
đổi cái tỉ lệ đấy chúng nó bớt lệch đúng
không? thay đổi đây là bao gồm cái việc
là các bạn tăng số lượng sồ cho các cái
lá thiếu số hoặc các bạn giảm số lượng
số cho cá đa số hoặc các bạn kết hợp cửa
hai đúng không? Chúng ta làm như vậy là
chúng ta phải chấp nhận là gì? Là chúng
ta sẽ làm thay đổi cái distribution
nhưng mà đấy là cái thứ chúng ta phải
phải làm đúng không? Thế thế nhưng mà
bây giờ ví dụ nhá chúng ta ví dụ các bạn
tưởng tượng là cái bài toán phân loại
người bị ung thư ấy đúng không? 100
người bình thường chỉ có hai ba người bị
ung bị ung ung thư thôi đúng không? tỉ
lệ nó rất là lệch nhau. Bây giờ mà các
bạn thực hiện balance data các bạn cho
nó thiện 50 50 thì bây giờ khi mà các
bạn huấn luyện mô hình như vậy mô hình
nó sẽ có cái hình dung nó sẽ nghĩ là gì
là ung thư là bệnh rất dễ gặp phải. Cứ
hai người là có một người bị ung thư.
Thế sau này khi mà đem nó đi triển khai
ấ nó sẽ có cái sướng nó sẽ dựn rất nhiều
người bị ung thư. Tại vì là trong quá
trình huấn luyện nó gặp rất là nhiều
người bị như vậy mà đúng không? Thế nên
là cái điều mà chúng ta làm cho dượng nó
cân bằng là chúng ta cho các cái sample
nó số lượng bằng nhau ấy là cái điều mà
không nên không nên đúng không? Không
nên làm như vậy. Cái thứ chúng ta nhắm
lấy là chỉ là gì để cho diện nó.
nó đỡ bị mất cân bằng thôi đúng không?
Đỡ bị mất cân bằng. Nó cũng sẽ không có
một cái nó cũng sẽ không có một cái giá
trị cụ thể là các bạn phải đưa về tỉ lệ
là bao nhiêu đâu. Tại vì là tỉ lệ bao
nhiêu là hợp lý nó còn phụ thuộc vào cái
tỉ lệ gốc ban đầu. Tỷ lệ gốc ban đầu nó
là 1 chia 100 nó sẽ khác mà tỷ lệ gốc
ban đầu nó là 1 chia 50 nó sẽ khác. Thế
chứ nó sẽ không có nó sẽ không có một
cái nó sẽ không có một cái mẫu số chung.
Thế thì mỗi một bài toán thường khi
người ta cân bằng người ta có thể ta sẽ
thử nhiều tỉ lệ khác nhau. Tức là lúc
ban đầuọi là 1 chia 1/ chia 100 thì bây
gi tôi sẽ đưa về 1/5 hoặc là 10 chia 2
xem cái kết quả cái nào nó tốt hơn. Được
chưa? Thế và một điều rất là quan trọng
là gì? Là khi các bạn cân bằng dữ liệu,
các bạn phải thực hiện cân bằng dữ liệu
sau khi các bạn đã phân chia dữ liệu
rồi. Phân chia thành bộ train, bộ
validation với bộ test rồi. Và các bạn
sẽ chỉ cân bằng dữ liệu trên bộ train
thôi. Được chưa? Các bạn phải phân chia
dữ liệu thành bộ train, bộ va, bộ test.
Rồi sau đó các bạn cân bằng dữ liệu chỉ
ở trên bộ train mà thôi. Không được thực
hiện cân bằng dữ liệu trên bộ variation
hoặc là bộ test. Các bạn biết vì sao
không? Vì sao tôi lại phải thực hiện cân
bằng dữ liệu? Các bạn chú ý nhá. Ở đây
mình nói là cân bằng dữ liệu nhưng các
bạn nhớ là gì? Cân bằng dữ liệu ở đây ý
mình là gì? là tôi muốn làm sao sao cho
cái tỉ lệ của các cái class nó đỡ lệch
hơn chứ không phải là làm cho số lượng
sample chúng bằng nhau chắc chắn chặn
nhá. Không phải như vậy. Được chưa? Câu
hỏi mình là vì sao tôi lại phải thực
hiện cân bằng dữ liệu sau khi tôi đã
phân chia thành bộ train, bộ va, bộ test
rồi và tôi chỉ được thực hiện trên bộ
train thôi. Nếu tôi làm ngược lại, nếu
tôi làm trước khi tôi phân chia dữ liệu
thì chuyện gì xảy ra?
Nào.
Đúng rồi. Data leckage chính xác.
Detalakish
dò rỉ dữ liệu. Có bạn nào giải thích rõ
hơn không? Vì sao data lckage ở đây ý
nghĩa là gì? Dò rỉ dữ liệu nghĩa là gì?
Đúng rồi, nó chính là liên quan đến data
lish. Chính xác. Bạn nào thấy cho mình
rõ hơn được không? Nếu ở đây tôi cân
bằng dữ liệu trước rồi tôi lại mới phân
chia thành bộ truy bộ vào bộ test thì
chuyện gì xảy ra?
Thuật ngữ thì đúng rồi. Đọc đượcên đọc
được cái tên thuật ngữ thì đúng rồi.
Nhưng mà data ở đây nghĩa là gì?
Phần trên nó có tính giống với test nên
máy nó học thuộc nên test không chuẩn.
Tức là sao mình không hiểu mình càng
rượu đây. Phần trên có tính giống với
test giống là giống cái gì
nào? Bạn nào giải thích cho mình ra
dataalic ở đây nghĩa là gì? Vì sao tôi
lại không được phép tôi cân bằng dữ liệu
trước rồi tôi mới phân chia thành bộ
truy bộ bộ va bộ test sau.
Ai giải thích được cho mình
[âm nhạc]
cheating á. Cheating như nào?
Av cheating tránh ra lận á. Ga lận như
nào
nào? Ai có thể giải thích cho mình là vì
sao tôi lại không được phép thực hiện
cân bằng dữ liệu trước khi tôi phân chia
dữ liệu mà tôi phải thực hiện sau khi
phân chia và tôi chỉ được thực hiện trên
bộ trin thôi. Tôi không được làm cái
điều này trên bộ vào hoặc là bộ test.
Ý là phần trên nó có một phần của bộ
test. Đúng rồi. Phần nếu chúng ta là nếu
chúng ta thực hiện balance data trước
khi chúng ta phân chia dữ liệu thì bộ
trê nó sẽ có một phần của bộ test. Vì
sao lại như vậy? Các bạn tưởng tượng
nhá. Ví dụ mình lấy một cái ví dụ là
chúng ta thực hiện Bent data là chúng ta
thực hiện over sampling đi đúng không?
Over sampling có nghĩa là gì? Tức là các
cái sample thuểu số ấy tôi sẽ nhân bẩn
hóa lên ví dụ như vậy đúng không? Ví dụ
lúc ban đầu nó có một phiên bản vì nó
mỗi một cái sample nó tôi nhân gấp năm
lên đi đúng không? Thì tôi cân bằng dữ
liệu trước như vậy sau tôi mới phân chia
dữ liệu thì sẽ có khả năng là gì? Là có
có những cái phiên bản nó rơi vào bộ
train, có những cái phiên bản nó rơi vào
bộ test đúng không? Những cái phiên bản
này nó giống y hệ hiệt nhau đúng không?
Giống y hệ hiệt nhau. Ví dụ bây giờ tôi
có năm phiên bản của cùng cái sample đi
thì bốn phiên bản rơi vào bộ train, một
phiên bản rơi vào bộ test. Thì theo về
mặt bản chất chúng nó giống y hiệt nhau.
Tức là nó cũng giống như kiểu là biệt
tôi trước khi thi tôi đã được luyện tập
trước với cái đề thi đấy. Đúng không?
Thì các bạn đánh giá mình nó sẽ không
còn chính xác nữa, nó sẽ không còn khách
quan nữa đúng không? Nó giống như kiểu
là trước khi đi mà để lộ đề trước á đúng
không? Cô bây giờ đáng nhẽ cô chỉ có 10
bộ đề thôi. Bây giờ cô photocopy thành
50 bộ sau đó cô lấy 40 bộ cho các bạn
học 10 bộ cô cho các bạn đi thi đạ đúng
không? Thì các bạn trong quá trình học
các bạn đã biết trước đề thi rồi thì lúc
này đánh giá nó không còn chính xác nữa
đúng không?
Rồi đấy là về balance data. Có bạn nào
có câu hỏi gì không? Có bạn nào có cái
thắc mắc gì là vì sao chúng ta lại phải
thể hiện cân bằng dữ liệu sau khi phân
chiến dữ liệu không?
Ok tiếp nhá. Thế thì bây giờ ấy đây các
bạn nhìn này. Đây khác biệt giữa over
sibling về under siing. Đây over sibling
ấ cái trên là over cái dưới là under.
Oversing nó có rất là nhiều cách để
người ta có thể thử oversampling nhưng
mà một trong số những cách rất là phổ
biến đó là người ta sẽ thực hiện người
ta sẽ tạo ra những cái rượu tổng hợp hay
gọi là sinic data. Sin dic là dữ liệu
tổng hợp dữ liệu tổng hợp nó là gì? Nó
giống kiểu các bạn nghe khái niệm nhựa
tổng hợp ấy. Nhựa tổng hợp nó là nhựa
nhưng mà nó có một vài những cái đặc
tính mới để nó giúp cho nhựa nó bền hơn,
nó tốt hơn. Nó làm sao đấy A BC YZ đúng
không? Thì nhựa tổng hợp thế nào thì cái
này y chang như vậy đúng không? Các bạn
tưởng tượng trong cái hình này nhá. Đúng
không? Ờ
>> em xin lỗi thầy tí em hỏi một câu đúng
không ạ? Bạn hỏi đi. K
>> bạn hỏi đi.
>> Cái chỗ vừa nãy thầy bảo là cân bằng dữ
liệu ấy ạ thì thầy bảo là
>> mình sẽ cân bằng ở bộ trên
>> tức là giảm giảm làm cho hai bộ ờ tức là
cái outcome của mình ấy và cái nó chung
là ví dụ như ung thư không ung thư đi
làm cho hai cái tật đấy nó tương đối là
tương đối là đồng đều nhau. Ví dụ khoảng
10 tỉ lệ 10 thôi chẳng hạn.
>> Nhưng mà em thì em hiểu nhá là cái tỉ lệ
1/100 này ấ nó sẽ vẫn tồn tại ở cái bộ
va và bộ test.
>> Chính xác. Đúng rồi, chính xác.
>> Thì em hỏi là cái việc mà mình làm cho
cái tỉ lệ này nó thay đổi ở cái bộ trên
ấy thì có ảnh hưởng đến việc học của máy
không?
>> Không, nó sẽ ảnh hưởng. Tức như này. Thế
đấy chính là lý do vì sao mà tôi mới tôi
chỉ điều chỉnh về là 1 chia 10 tôi không
tỉ lệ thành 1 chia 1. Tại vì rõ ràng khi
chúng ta thể hiện cân bằng dữ liệu thì
cái tỉ lệ chắc chắn nó sẽ không giữ được
rồi đúng không? Chắc chúng ta sẽ không
thể nào đúng không? Tôi cân bằng dữ liệu
là tôi thay đổi tỉ lệ. Tôi sẽ không thể
đảm bảo là cái tỉ lệ của bộ chuyên với
bộ van nó không bằng nhau. Nhưng đấy là
điều chúng ta phải chấp nhận. Tại vì
chúng ta muốn là mô hình làm sao nó có
cơ hội nó được tiếp xúc với cái s class
nó thường xuyên hơn đúng không? Thì là
cái việc cái việc mà điều chỉ tỉ lệ là
buộc phải chấp nhận rồi đúng không?
Không thể nào vừa cân bằng dữ liệu lại
vừa đòi hỏi là tỉ lệ được giữ nguyên
được
>> không? Em em hiểu em hiểu là bộ bộ trên
chắc chắn là nó sẽ phải thay đổi rồi.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Nhưng mà em hỏi là cái việc mà thay đổi
cái tỉ lệ tự nhiên ở trong bộ trên ấy nó
khác so với lại cái hiện thực mà nó sẽ
phải thực hành ở trong cái bộ va và
test.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Thì nó có ảnh hưởng đến cái việc học của
máy không thôi. Sợ là nó có học sai hay
không hoặc là như không. Còn nếu mà thầy
bảo không thì ok. Thầy bảo vấn đề thì
học tiếp. Thường nó sẽ ảnh hưởng theo
cái xu thế này. Tức là thông thường thì
nó sẽ làm cho cái performance của mình
trên cái đập thiểu số nó tốt lên. Nhưng
cái giá chúng ta có thể phải trả là gì?
Là có thể performance của mô hình trên
class nó sẽ tồi đi. Nó giống như kiểu là
cái sự chú ý của mô hình nó là 100%. Thì
bây giờ tôi muốn mô hình nó chú ý hơn
vào cái class thì chúng ta sẽ phải hy
sinh một chút cái performance trên class
đa số. Thông thường là nó sẽ là như thế.
Thường nó sẽ thế.
>> Vâng.
>> Rồi.
Ok. Có nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Các bạn nhớ nhá. Nhớ nhá. Gọi là balance
data. Nhưng các bạn nhớ là gì? Mục đích
của chúng ta là gì? Là làm cho dữ liệu
nó đỡ bị mất cân bằng hơn. Đúng không?
Chỉ cần nó đỡ một cái bảng hơn đã là tốt
rồi. Tốt rồi.
Khi mà tỉ lệ giữa các cái class ấy nó
khi mà tỉ lệ giữa các cái class ấ nó
lệch nhau không quá nhiều. Ví dụ nó chỉ
lệch nhau khoảng một khoảng hai ba lần ý
thì người ta thông thường người ta sẽ
không cần phải cân bằng. Người ta chỉ
cân bằng thường khi nó rất là lệch. Ví
dụ nó cập gấp 5, gấp 10 hoặc gấp 50 100
lần thì chúng ta mới c c cân bằng. Thế
còn ví dụ chỉ lệch khoảng hai ba lần
thôi thì thường ta sẽ không cân bằng dữ
liệu. Nh
thế các bạn nhá. Nói về cân bằng dữ liệu
thì nó có rất nhiều thuật toán khác
nhau. Đế không chúng ta thực hành chúng
ta sẽ nói kỹ hơn. Nhưng mà đây các bạn
ví dụ đây đúng không? Nói về over link
đúng không? Cách rất là đơn giản là gì?
Là tôi sẽ tạo ra rượu tổng hợp. Rượu
tổng hợp là những cái rượu mà nó được
tạo ra từ những cái rượu gốc nhưng mà nó
có những đặc tính mới. Thì ví dụ đây các
bạn nhìn đây ở đây đúng không? Ví dụ đây
tôi có cái class màu cam là class thiểu
số. Class màu xanh là class đa màu màu
xanh hình tròn á là class đa số. Thế bây
giờ tôi muốn tạo tôi muốn tạo thêm dữ
liệu, tôi muốn overing cho cái class
thiểu số thì tôi sẽ tạo thêm. Tạo thêm
bằng cách nào? Ví dụ tôi tạo ra một cái
sle mới, tôi dựa trên bốn cái sample cũ
chẳng hạn, đúng không các bạn nhớ không?
Bốn cái sample gần nhau này, tôi lấy một
cái điểm trung bình tôi ra cái điểm mới
này đúng không? Đây đúng không? Nó giống
như kiểu nhựa tổng hợp đúng không? Nhựa
tổng hợp là nhựa nhưng mà nó có những
đặc điểm mới. Được chưa? Đây là gọi là
overing. Thế còn undering thì nó cũng có
rất nhiều cách khác nhau. Th ví dụ một
cách rất là cơ bản là gì? Bây giờ người
ta sẽ xen vào những cái sle nào nó gần
với với những cái sle thuộc class. Tức
là bây giờ under là tôi sẽ phải bỏ bớt
sle thuộc class đa số đi đúng không? Thì
bây giờ nó sẽ làm kiểu gì? Nó sẽ làm
theo kiểu là bây giờ ấy những cái sample
nào thuộc class đa số mà nó rất là gần
với những cái sle thuộc clểu số thì tôi
sẽ bỏ những cái điểm này đi. Đó là đây
không? Hai cái điểm đ không một ờ hình
tròn là đa số, hình vuông là thiểu số
đúng không? Thì bây giờ cái ông tròn này
nó gần cái ông vuông này tôi bỏ ông tròn
đi đúng không? Thì tôi sẽ bỏ vớt cái
simple đa số đi. Đây là người ta tiện
under link hoặc người ta kết hợp cả hai
cái kết hợp cả hai cả over cả under.
Được chưa?
Rồi đây là liên quan đến dữ liệu dạng
dạng bản thì người ta hay làm như này.
Sau này các bạn sẽ còn nhiều kiểu dữ
liệu khác ví dụ dạng văn bản và dạng
hình ảnh. Thì thông thường ấy thông
thường với thật ra undering thì luôn
luôn là dễ. Under samling bao giờ cũng
dễ. Tại vì các bạn bớt đi cái cũ mà bớt
đi thì bao giờ cũng dễ. Thêm vào cái mới
thì mới khó. Nói về order nói về over
sammeling ấy thì nếu các bạn có dệu dạng
văn bản over sampling rất là khó. Thì về
văn bản ấ overling các bạn tạo ra những
cái sample mới thì làm sao để cái sample
này nó vẫn có ý nghĩa thì rất là khó.
Nhưng mà over sampling với ảnh thì rất
là dễ. Với ảnh thì over cực kỳ dễ luôn.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì với ảnh ấy các bạn có
thể có những cái phép biến đổi để các
bạn tạo những cái ảnh mới dựa trên cái
ảnh cũ. Ví dụ là các bạn lật ảnh, lật
ảnh trái phải trái hoặc các bạn ờ các
bạn gọi là các bạn rotate, các bạn xoay
nó đi một góc 5°ộ hoặc là các bạn thay
đổi về cái độ sáng, độ tương phản hoặc
độ bão hòa. Thế là các bạn có thể tạo ra
một đống ảnh mới rồi. Với mảng computer
vision thì các bạn over xem này cực kỳ
dễ luôn nhưng mà với mảng NLP nó sẽ khó
ăn hơn rất là nhiều. Thế còn với dừa
rộng bảng thì đây kỹ thuật chủ yếu là nó
sẽ có kiểu kiểu như thế này. Đấy
đúng rồi. Chính xác. Over là tăng, under
là giảm. Tăng thì phải tăng cho ông
thiểu số mà giảm là phải giảm cho ông đa
số.
Có thư viện chứ. Đây là mình nói lý
thuyết thôi. Còn tất nhiên lúc chúng ta
thực hành chúng ta dùng thư viện chứ sức
đâu mà chúng ta ngồi làm thủ công này.
Làm thủ công thì cũng được nhưng mà mất
thời gian đúng không? Thư viện nó làm
cho chúng ta rất là rất là tốt rồi nhá.
Rồi tiếp nhá. Cái đấy là có câu hỏi gì
nữa không? Và nhớ nhá. Đây là đây là cái
dành cho bài toán classification nhá.
Regression thì không có khái niệm class
đa số clểu số đâu nhá. Regession không
có khái niệm đấy đâu nhá. Các bạn gặp
bài toán viion thì không có khái niệm là
các bạn đi ngồi over với under đâu nhá.
Không có balance data nhá.
Tiếp này. Tiếp này. Thì bây chúng ta sẽ
nói tiếp về cái ngá nghiệm nữa là liên
quan đến trực quan hóa dữ liệu. Thì như
cái buổi chúng ta nói về cái data
pipeline ấy, chúng ta sẽ có một cái bước
là chúng ta trực quán hóa dữ liệu. Vì
sao chúng ta phải trực quán hóa dữ liệu?
Đ mình nhắc lại tại vì sau này các bạn
đi làm các bạn sẽ làm việc với những
người mà người ta cũng chả có cái
background giống như các bạn đâu đúng
không? Người ta sẽ là sếp rồi sẽ là
khách hàng rồi sẽ là đồng nghiệp của
những team khác. họ sẽ không có
background về detation, về machining.
Các bạn mà cứ báo cáo số liệu toàn con
số với bảng thì nó rất là khó hiểu đúng
không? Thì bây gi các bạn sẽ làm ra dùng
những cái hình vẽ để cho người ta dễ
hình dung, [hắng giọng] dễ hình dung hơn
là cái dượu bạn nó là về cái gì đúng
không? Thế thì trong Python ấy thì nó có
rất nhiều các cái thư viện khác nhau
dành cho cái mảng chức quán hán dữ liệu
là đây là data visualization. Nhưng mà
trong đó thì trong đó thì có trong đó
thì có cái thư viện quốc dân, cái thư
viện nổi tiếng nhất là thư viện Map
List. Đây là thư viện mà nó là thư viện
nền tảng cho cái phần liên quan đến trực
văn hóa dữ liệu. Sau đó thì từ cái thư
viện này sẽ có rất nhiều những cái thư
viện khác nó xây dựng on top của cái thư
viện này. Tức là nó ở bên trong nó gọi
những cái hàm của map of thì một trong
số những cái thư viện đấy là thư viện
CBON. Thư viện CBON thì trong quá trình
chúng ta thực hành chúng ta sẽ dùng cả
hai thư viện này. Dùng cả hai thứ. Đấy.
[khịt mũi] Thế bây giờ nói qua một chút
về một vài những cái biểu đồ. Tức là
trong hai cái thư viện này nó có rất
nhiều biểu đồ. Cái cbon nó phải có đến
hàng trăm còn mrip nó cũng phải có đến
hàng chục biểu đồ khác nhau rất là
nhiều. Nhưng mà sau này các bạn đi làm
các bạn ch các bạn chỉ hay sử dụng
khoảng ba bốn cái biểu đồ cơ bản thôi.
Thường thì mỗi người sẽ có một vài những
cái biểu đồ ưa thích mà họ hay dùng. Thế
các bạn ấy cũng không cần phải nhớ trước
là có những loại biểu đồ gì đâu. Mình sẽ
giới thiệu các bạn những cái biểu đồ cơ
bản mà mình thấy là nó áp dụng được
trong nhiều tình huống nhất, nhiều loại
dữ liệu nhất. Còn sau này khi mà các bạn
đi làm các bạn dùng cái nào nhiều là tự
nhiên các bạn nhớ ngay. Ấ mà đấy các bạn
không cần phải chủ động các bạn ngồi học
thuộc hay nhớ cái gì cả. Nhất là bây giờ
có AI rồi chúng con càng càng dễ dàng
hơn.
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Bây gi chúng ta sẽ đi qua một chút về
một vài những cái loại biểu đồ trong
trong trong Python cho dùng cái thư viện
này. Đây các bạn nhìn đây đây là một vài
cái loại biểu đồ các bạn có thể vẽ đúng
không? Bạn nào mà các bạn học I bạn học
cái bài các bạn học về cái task writing
thì các bạn không còn xa lạ gì với các
cái biểu đồ này đúng không? Đấy nên đầu
tiên này ví dụ này đầu tiên thì có một
cái loại biểu đồ mình dùng rất là nhiều
đặc biệt là với dữ dệu dạng số đó là
người ta gọi là histogram. Cái này mà
các bạn học I cũng dùng rất là nhiều.
Histogram là cái dạng biểu đồ mà nó sẽ
có những cái cột này hoặc có một vài cái
biến thể nó sẽ viết theo hàng. Mỗi một
cột nó sẽ thể hiện cái số lượng sample
thuộc vào cái nhóm đấy đúng không? Thông
thường thì trục hoành sẽ là cái giá trị
còn trục tung sẽ là cái số lượng. Được
chưa? Trục hoành là cái giá trị trục
tung là số lượng. Và thông thường thì
với cái histogram này người ta sẽ trục
hoành nó sẽ giá trị là theo khoảng. Tức
là ví dụ khoảng từ x đến y thì tôi có sự
từng này sample. Từ y đến z tôi có từng
này simple. Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Ví dụ các
bạn nhìn cái cái cột liên quan đến cái
đến cái đến cái
đi đúng không? H này đúng không? Người
ta tuổi ví dụ người ta phân chia là từ
20 đến 2 năm 25 đến 30 đến 35 ví dụ như
vậy đúng không? Thì nếu cái rượu gốc của
bạn ấy nó là rượu rời dạc sẵn rồi, ví dụ
như là tuổi tuổi hoặc là lớp chẳng hạn
thì nó sẽ tự đế nó chạy thôi. Còn nếu nó
là dữ liệu liên tục ví dụ là mức lương
hoặc là mức lương hoặc là chiều cao
chẳng hạn nó giá trị liên tục nó vô số
giá trị khác nhau thì người ta sẽ thường
người ta sẽ thư viện sẽ tự động sẽ rời
giá khóa giá trị cho các bạn. Tôi cứ lấy
trong khỏa trong khỏa trong khỏe. Thì
tóm lại là như thế này. Tóm lại biểu đồ
nó lại trông như thế này. Được chưa? Đây
loại biểu đồ dùng rất là nhiều tại vì là
nó liên quan đến dữ liệu đoạn số. Thì
các bạn thấy là khi bạn dùng cái biểu đồ
này nó sẽ tạo mặc định là nó sẽ tạo ra
mỗi một cái biểu đồ con cho trong cái
biểu đồ lớn đúng không? Có cái khung
khung lớn ở ngoài cùng. Trong cái khung
lớn này các bạn có những chín cái biểu
đồ con được chưa? Tại vì cái bộ này nó
có chín cột thì nó thành như này. Bộ các
bạn có nhiều cột hơn nó sẽ là cột khác
được chưa? Đây là cái histogram đây đồ
mình dùng rất là nhiều tại vì rượu dạng
số mà dạng số các bạn rất là gặp rất là
nhiều. Loại thứ hai là gì? Cái loại thứ
hai người to là density plot. Density
nghĩa là mật độ. Đây là một biểu đố liên
quan đến mật độ. Thật ra thì hai biểu bè
nó tương đương nhau thôi các bạn ạ.
Chẳng qua là một ông là ông phiên bản
rời dạc, một ông là phiên bản liên tục
thôi chứ ta tính chất nó chả khác gì
nhau. Các bạn cứ thể nhìn vào xem trục
hoành thì giống nhau nhá. Trục tung thì
đấy các bạn. trục tung thì một ông là
những cái cột như này khi các bạn rời
dạc rồi còn một ông là một cái đường như
này là khi các bạn liên tục quóa nó chưa
liên tục quóa nó
thế đây là hai loại biểu đồ đầu tiên
đúng không hai biểu biểu đồ dùng nếu mà
các bạn dùng cả hai biểu đồ này thì ví
dụ các bạn có thể là lúc mà các bạn làm
việc với rượu dạng rời dạc các bạn nhìn
vào ông này liên tục các bạn nhìn màu
ông này kiểu kiểu như vậy được chưa có
thể dùng một trong hai cái hoặc là dùng
cả hai cái kết hợp với nhau
đấy một cái loại nữa là box plot cái này
thì mình thấy rất nhiều tutorial người
ta hay dùng nhưng mà th mình thì mình
không dùng nhiều lắm. Bóc bóc này có đặc
điểm là cái cái biểu đồ trông giống hình
cái kim tiêm. Mấy cái điểm tròn tròn này
nó thiện phân bố dữ liệu nhưng mà thôi
cái này các bạn không cần để ý đâu. Các
bạn nhìn nhìn thấy cái hình chính là cái
là cái cái giống hình kim tiêm này đúng
không? Cái điểm dưới cùng nó là min trên
cùng nó là max. Còn cái cái cái hộp này
nó chính là tứ phân vị. Đấy cái đường
màu xanh lá cây thì là median là trung
vị. Còn dưới là first quanti, trên là
first quant thôi đúng không? Cái này
mình ít khi mình dùng ít mình dùng. Bởi
vì thế là nó cũng chả có thêm thông tin
gì. Mình có thể mình có những cái report
mình nhìn được những cái này hết rồi.
Mình ít khi mình in ra cái này nhưng mà
đây cũng là biểu đồ rất là phổ biến. Box
plot.
Thế là ba biểu đồ rồi. Ba biểu đồ này ấ
đều được xếp vào dạng là biểu đồ đơn
biến. Tại vì sao gọi là đơn biến? Tại vì
là mỗi một cái biểu đồ con nó chỉ thể
hiện cho một biến thôi. Đúng không? Mỗi
biểu đồ con là thể cho một biến. Thế bây
giờ tôi sẽ có một loại biểu đồ là biểu
đồ đa biến. Biểu đồ đa biến là trong cái
biểu đồ nó sẽ thể mối quan hệ giữa các
cái biến nhiều hơn một biến với nhau. Ví
dụ đầu tiên các bạn có cái gì? Các bạn
có cái coration magic plot đúng không?
Đây in ra như này. Tất nhiên là trong
Python các bạn có thể có các bạn dùng
các bạn có rất nhiều cách để các bạn có
thể in ra cái ma trận này dưới dạng là đ
đơn thuần thôi nhưng mà nhìn nó sẽ xấu.
Đây là một cách để các bạn ra các bạn có
thể dec nhìn trông nó đẹp hơn. Đ các bạn
nhìn này đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ có một
cái ma trận có ma một cái mảng hai chiều
là một cái ma trận ma trận vuông đúng
không? N hàng n cột với n là số lượng số
lượng cột của bạn đúng không? Cái bộ
rượu này đúng không? Mình bộ rượu này là
nó có nhiều cột có những cột là feature
và có cột là target đúng không? Mình gộp
hết lại thì mình có chín cột tổng cộng
thì các bạn sẽ có một cái ma trận như
này. Được chưa? Đây là ma trận thể hiện
là cái hệ số tương quan giữa các cái cặp
biến với nhau đúng không? M trận này nó
có đặc điểm gì các bạn? Đường chéo chính
thì nó bằng 1. Hiển nhiên rồi. Tại vì là
hệ số tương quan của một số với chính nó
thì luôn bằng 1. Hệ số tương quan của
một biến với chính nó thì luôn bằng 1
đúng không? Thế ngoài ra các bạn nhìn
thấy cái to nhận này có đặc điểm gì nữa
các bạn?
Nó có đặc điểm gì đây? Nó các cái phần
tử giá trị nó đối xứng với nhau qua
đường chéo chính đúng không? Ma trận mà
các cái phần tử đối xứng với nhau, giá
trị đối xứng với nhau qua đường chéo
chính mình gọi là ma trận gì các bạn
nhỉ?
Ma trận mà có các phần tử đối xứng với
nhau qua đường chéo chính thì mình gọi
là ma trận gì các bạn?
Ma trận gì?
Đây này. 0,13 0,13 nhá đúng không? 0,14
0,14 nhá đúng không? 0,15 0,15 nhá đúng
không? Các cái phân tử đối xứng nhau qua
đường chò chính này nó bằng nhau này. Ma
trận này người ta gọi là ma trận gì các
bạn?
Đúng rồi, ma trận đối xứng thôi. Ma trận
đối xứng symmetric magic. Đúng rồi. Được
chưa?
Đúng không? Đây. Và các bạn nh các bạn
có một cái thang màu ở bên phải nữa này.
Thang màu bên phải nữa. Được chưa?
Nhớ là cái này chỉ áp dụ cho dữ liệu
dạng số thôi nhá. L phân loại các bạn
không có cái này đâu. Được chưa?
Tiếp một cái nữa buổi cũng khá là hay.
Cái này gọi là scatter magic plot.
Skatter magic plus. Cái buổi các bạn in
ra trông như này. Cái đường chéo chính
ấy nó chính là cái histogram. Được chưa?
Đường chéo chính thì chính là histogram.
Thế còn các cái phần tử mà không nằm ở
trong đường chéo chính ý thì nó sẽ thể
hiện là cái trực quân hóa khi mà tôi chỉ
quan tâm đến hai biến thôi. Ví dụ cái
ông này là tôi chỉ quan tâm đến cái
pregnancy với cả tôi quan tâm đến cái
glucozer thôi. Tôi vẽ ra nó được như thế
này. Được chưa? Đấy thì ngoại trừ cái
đường trở chính nó chính là đúng không?
Điều chính nó chính là histogram này.
Histogram này đây này chính là nó đấy
đúng không? Nhưng cái chỗ còn lại nó thể
hiện là khi mà tôi chỉ chừa quân hóa tôi
quan tâm đến hai biến thôi thì trông mặt
mụn nó trông như nào được chưa? Thì đây
là một vài những cái biểu đồ cơ bản
trong map kết hợp với cảbon đây. Cbon là
các bạn dùng này này. Cbon nó sử dụng on
top của map M mapp. Tức là ở bên trong
nó gọi cái hàm của maplip nên là hai thư
bư thích với nhau rất là mạnh. Các bạn
có thể dùng trộn hai thư viện với nhau
rất là dễ dàng.
Thế đây là những cái trường hợp mà các
bạn có những cái biểu đồ các bạn có thể
gọi một dòng là xong. Các bạn tổ sự sẵn
rồi các bạn chỉ đưa đâ đưa dữ liệu vào
là xong. Thế nhưng mà đôi khi thì khi mà
các bạn dùng maplip trong python ấy, đôi
khi các bạn sẽ phải ngồi các bạn vẽ thủ
công. Vẽ thủ công tức là vẫn có những
cái hàm nhưng mà hàm nó sẽ không kiểu là
đến tận răng như này đâu. Tức là không
phải là các bạn gọi một phát là xong
luôn mà các bạn sẽ phải gọi nhiều bước
làm nhiều thứ khác nhau. Thế thì để
chúng ta có thể chúng ta tự mình xây
dựng được những cái những cái biểu đồ
của mình thì các bạn sẽ cần phải biết
một vài những cái khái niệm cơ bản trong
map of lip nhá. Trong maplip ấ các bạn
muốn vẽ cái gì thì vẽ. thì người ta sẽ
có hai cái khái niệm
lớn nhất. Đầu tiên thì trong map public
ấy người ta sẽ có một cái khái niệm
người ta gọi là figer. Figer fixer khi
bên trái figer là cái khung màu đỏ này.
Figer nó là cái gì? Figer các bạn tưởng
tượng nó là một cái khung lớn được chưa?
Figer nó là một cái khung lớn để các bạn
vẽ vời thì các bạn vẽ vào đấy. Được
chưa? Các bạn muốn vẽ bạn muốn làm gì
các bạn sẽ vẽ vào cái khung lớn. Được
chưa? Fixer là cái khung lớn.
Các bạn tưởng tượng cái fixer này giống
như kiểu cái bàn ăn ấy. Được chưa? Figer
giống như kiểu cái bàn ăn. Các bạn đặt
gì các bạn phải đặt lên bàn ăn. Được
chưa? Figer là cái khung lớn là tương
đối với cái bàn ăn này. Đúng không? Bên
trong figure ấy các bạn có thể có một
hoặc là có nhiều những cái access.
Access nó là cái gì? Access thì trong
mapp người ta gọi nó là khung con nhá.
Khung con. Còn trong thực tế nếu figure
nó là cái bàn ăn thì access nó là những
cái đĩa được thức ăn. Được chưa? Các bạn
bắt buộc phải có một cái bàn ăn đúng
không? Các bạn phải có một cái bàn ăn,
phải có một cái figure và các bạn có thể
có 1 2 hoặc các bạn có thể có nhiều cái
access. Mỗi cái assess là một cái đĩa
được thức ăn. Được chưa? Tối hiểu là
phải có một access không có thể có 2 34
tùy các bạn. Được chưa? Figer là khung
lớn, asset là khung con đúng không? Thế
bây giờ sau này các bạn có đồ ăn đúng
không? Các bạn vẽ vừa cái gì là các bạn
phải vẽ? Là các bạn phải vẽ vào cái
access đúng không? Giống kiểu các bạn có
cái hoa quả thức ăn ấ các bạn phải đựng
vào đĩa chứ đúng không? Làm gì có ai
đựng thẳng vào bàn đâu đúng không? Thế
thì bây giờ tôi có đồ ăn là tôi phải
đựng vào đĩa. Đĩa tôi để trên trên bàn
đúng không? Tức là gì? Tức là bây giờ
các bạn muốn vẽ cái gì ấ là các bạn phải
vẽ vào cái asset. Sau đó asset thì người
ta đặt vào trong cái fcker thế là xong
đúng không? Thông thường cái trường hợp
cơ bản ấy là người ta sẽ có một figure
và một asset thôi. Đây là trường hợp cơ
bản. Còn trường hợp mà các bạn có nhiều
thứ để vẽ các bạn sẽ có nhiều asset. Đây
ví dụ đây này. Đây các bạn nhớ không?
Đây này. Các bạn có một figure và các
bạn có chín cái access này đúng không?
Mỗi cái khung con chính là một cái biểu
đồ con này. Được chưa? Các bạn vẽ vời gì
là các bạn vẽ lên khung con rồi khung
con lại đặt ở trong khung lớn đúng
không? Chứ không ai người ta vẽ người ta
lại vẽ thẳng vào khung lớn cả đúng
không? Không ai vẽ thẳng vào fcker.
Fcker nó chỉ cái khung bao quát khung
lớn nhất thôi. Các bạn đặt là các bạn
phải đặt cái khung con vào đấy. Vẽ gì là
vẽ vào khung con. Được chưa? Đấy. Bây
giờ thế thì khi mà các bạn vẽ ví dụ
trong trường hợp này, trường hợp cơ bản
là gì? là sẽ bị thiếu một không lớn và
một không con thôi. Tức là gì? Một
figure và một access. Thế bây giờ vẽ bạn
vẽ cái gì? Thông thường thông thường ý
khi mà nói về vẽ người ta thường sẽ có
hai kiểu vẽ. Một là vẽ trong không gian
hai chiều là kiểu phổ biến nhất và hai
cái đó là ít phổ biến hơn là vẽ trong
không gian ba chiều. Không gian ba chiều
các bạn sẽ ít gặp lắm, rất ít khi các
bạn gặp không vẽ trong không gian ba
chiều. Các bạn thường các bạn sẽ chỉ gặp
vẽ trong không gian hai chiều thôi đúng
không? Thì vẽ trong không gian hai chiều
nó chính là cái hệ trục tọa độ dec oxy
đấy đúng không? Oxy ox là trục hoành oy
là chục tung đấy đúng không? Thì bây giờ
muốn vẽ thì các bạn phải có một cái
thông thường vẽ là các bạn phải có một
cái hệ trục tọa độ trước đúng không? Bắt
đầu ox với oy. Thế bây giờ ấy các cái
trục này thì nó tiếng Anh gọi là axit
đúng không? Axit thì là trục đúng không?
X axit thì là trục hoành. Y axit thì là
trục tung đúng không? Thì mỗi một cái
trục này các bạn sẽ có thành phần gì?
Thứ nhất các bạn phải có thành phần là
cái stick. Stick là cái gì? Stick là cái
thang chia. Ví dụ bạn thấy là cái trục
hoành thang chia này nó 0 1 2 3 4 này
đúng không? Đấy là cái stick của nó. Còn
thang chia của cái trung tung là 0,51
đấy đúng không? Đấy là cái thang chia
của nó. stick và ngoài stick ra nó phải
có một cái nữa là cái label label ví dụ
trục hoành là thời gian, trục tung là
cái gì đấy đúng không? Chụp tung là
lương hay là cái gì đấy đúng không? Mỗi
một cái trục này nó sẽ phải có thứ nhất
là cái thang chia và thứ hai là nó sẽ
phải có cái tên của nó. Được chưa?
À trong trong map ấy nó có một cách đặt
tên nó hơi dở một chút. Map nó đặt tên
nó hơi dở một chút. Đó là gì? Các bạn
nhìn này. Cái từ assistit với cái từ
assess này. Các bạn biết là hai từ này
trong tiếng Anh nó liên quan gì đến nhau
không? Asit và access. Hai từ này trong
tiếng Anh các bạn biết là hai từ này nó
liên quan gì với nhau.
Hai từ này trong tiếng Anh liên quan gì
nhở? Asit thì access
mày trong tiếng Anh ấy nó là đúng rồi
một cái hệ một ông là số ít một ông số
nhiều đúng không? Axit là số ít, axit số
nhiều, axit là trục, axit là nhiều trục.
Thế nhưng mà trong m hai này chẳng liên
quan đến nhau cả. Hai này hoàn toàn
không có không có ý nghiệm là ông này là
một chục, ông kia là nhiều chục. Không
phải như vậy. Nó chỉ đơn giản a là cái
khung con và axit là cái trục mỗi thế
thôi. Nhưng cách đặt tên này nó sẽ hơi
hơi dễ gây ra nhầm lẫn. Được chưa? Thế
thấy nhá. Đúng không? Chúng ta có khung
lớn là fixer là cái bàn ăn một hoặc
nhiều khung con là cái access là cái đĩa
được thức ăn. Vẽ vời gì là có giống bạn
đặt thức ăn. Thức ăn thì phải đặt trong
cái đĩa đĩa đặt trong bàn đúng không? Vẽ
các bạn sẽ vẽ trên access này. Đấy chưa?
Thì sau khi các bạn có cái trục xong rồi
các bạn vẽ thì vẽ thôi. Đúng đây các bạn
vẽ đường thì hình sin này. Hình sin như
này đúng đây là đây là đường trong không
gian 2D đúng không? Trong không gian hai
chiều đấy đúng không? B các bạn nhìn ví
dụ ở đây đúng không? Một là cái khung
lớn, hai là cái khung con đúng không?
Năm là trục tung sáu là trục hoành. Trục
tung trục hoành đều có thang chia đều có
tên có cả tên. Cái bốn là cái label của
cả cái biểu đồ này đúng không? Có cái
đường không dân 2D này. Đúng đường đồ
thị hình sin này đúng không? Đây là cách
người ta vẽ một cái đồ thị cơ bản. Được
chưa? Thế ngoài ra thì các cái đồ thị
trong MP ấ có thể một có thêm một vài
cái yếu tố hỗ trợ nữa. Hỗ trợ có nghĩa
là gì? Tức là ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ là bây
giờ các bạn thấy là bây giờ mà các bạn
để nguyên này, các bạn mà để như này các
bạn muốn gióng hàng gióng cột thì nhìn
nó sẽ khó khó gióng đúng cái điểm này
hoành là bao nhiêu, tung là bao nhiêu
gióng nó sẽ khó. Thì bây giờ để cho
gióng nó dễ hơn ấy các bạn sẽ có một cái
khái niệm là green. Green là cái lưới
đúng không? cái lưới cái lưới thì bây
giờ khi mà các bạn có cái win này thì
khi mà các bạn có cái win này thì dóng
sẽ dễ hơn đúng không? Gióng hàng gióng
cột nó sẽ dễ. Dóng hàng dóng cột nó sẽ
dễ. Thế đây một cái cái thứ hai nữa là
gì? Một cái thứ hai nữa là trong lúc các
bạn vẽ ấ nếu các bạn chỉ vẽ một đường
thì không sao. Các bạn vẽ năm sáu đường
trong cùng một cái đườ trong cùng một
cái đồ thị chẳng hạn thì mặc định là map
ấ nó sẽ tạo ra nó sẽ dùng những cái màu
khác nhau. Ví d một màu vàng một màu cam
một màu tím một màu đỏ. phân biệt những
cái đường này. Thế nhưng mà chúng ta
thường chúng ta sẽ cần phải có một cái
đường phải có một cái bảng chú thích.
Chú thích là gì? Là cái đường màu này nó
là cái gì? Cái đường màu kia nó là cái
gì? Đúng không? Chúng ta phải có một cái
bảng chú thích để chúng ta chỉ ra là gì?
Là cái đường này nó có ý nghĩa gì? Đường
kia nó có ý nghĩa gì
đúng không? Đấy thì trong map ấ người ta
gọi đó là legend. Legend thì nó chính là
cái bảng chú thích. Và có một cái điểm
rất là hay là gì? Là khi các bạn dùng
map public ấ các bạn chỉ ra là tôi có
muốn dùng cái bảng chú thích này hay
không. Nếu các bạn chỉ ra là các bạn
muốn dùng ấ nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ tìm cho
bạn một cái chỗ nó phù hợp nhất để nó
gắn cái bảng nó vào chứ còn các bạn
không cần phải chỉ ra là tôi muốn gắn ở
góc trên bên trái hay là góc dưới bên
phải đâu. Các bạn không cần làm như vậy.
M tự động nó sẽ tìm cho bạn xem là cái
chỗ nào chỗ phù hợp nhất để các bạn điền
cái bảng này.
Ở nó cũng có thể coi là cái phiên bản
Python dành cho nó. Nó cũng mở ho toàn
nhưng mà nhưng mà map public là chuyên
về vẽ. Còn ml thì nó làm nhiều thứ nữa,
nó còn tính toán các thứ nữa nhưng mà nó
còn tính toán thì cộng trừ ma trận các
thứ nhiều thứ nữa. Nhưng mà m là nó chỉ
chuyên về vẽ thôi. Chỉ chuyên về vẽ
thôi. Tức là nó là nó nó cái nó cũng là
nó cũng có cái điểm giống nhau là vẽ
những cái đồ thị đây. Nhưng mà cái này
nó chỉ chuyên về vẽ thôi. Nó nó không nó
không nó không mạnh về tính toán. Tính
toán là người ta dùng với 5 pi.
Rồi thì đấy là liên quan đến chữ văn
hóa. Đấy ch quan hóa thì nó cũng không
phải cái gì nó quá phức tạp đâu các bạn
ạ. Các bạn cũng chả cần phải nhớ đâu.
Các bạn dùng các bạn cứ làm việc một
thời gian các bạn cái nào các bạn dùng
nhiều tự nhên các bạn nhớ ngay. Mà bây
giờ có có chat TV nữa thì các bạn có nhớ
các bạn chả phải nhớ luôn. Nhưng mà các
bạn ít nhất các bạn biết là có những cái
loại biểu đồ gì sau này các bạn c dùng
các bạn biết đúng không? Đấ thế đấy là
về quân hóa dữ liệu rồi. Ok. Có b nào có
câu hỏi gì không?
Có nào có có thắc mắc gì không?
Thông thường về Map thì mình mình cũng
chỉ nhớ được khoảng khoảng khoảng khoảng
10 cái biểu đồ mình hay dùng thôi. Còn
những biểu đồ mà những cái gì mà nó là
lạ lại mình ít dùng thì khi nào mình
dùng thì mình thì mình search thôi
nhá. Đấy là những cái biểu đồ mà rất là
cơ bản dùng rất là nhiều trong.
Thế bây giờ chúng ta sang cái phần tiếp
theo. Hôm nay nốt buổi này với cả chắc
là chắc là vặn vẹo thêm một tí của buổi
ngày mai nữa là chúng ta xong phần lý
thuyết rồi. Sau tức là xong phần lý
thuyết đầu tiên rồi sau chúng ta sẽ có
khoảng ba buổi liền là chỉ có thực hành
thôi. Sau đó là chúng ta sẽ xen kẽ một
lý thuyết với một thực hành nhá. Hôm nay
chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau chúng ta cùng nhau
tìm hiểu về các cái thuật toán trong
machining. Trong machining nó có rất
nhiều thuật toán. Nó phải có khoảng vài
chục thuật toán cơ. Thế nhưng mà thật ra
ấy thì các bạn không cần phải biết hết
những thỏi toán này. Các bạn chỉ nắm
được một vài những th toán cơ bản. Người
ta hay sử dụng nhiều thôi. Những tội
toán cơ bản signature trong machin thôi.
Còn có nhiều tộ toán nó ít phổ biến hơn
thì các bạn cũng không nhất thiết là các
bạn phải tìm hiểu hết. Tại vì cho chúng
ta cũng tìm hiểu hết nó cũng không thể
làm gì cả. Các bạn biết những cái cơ bản
hay dùng là được rồi. Được chưa? N chúng
ta sẽ nói về các cái thuật toán trong
machining.
Thuật toán thì
thì các bạn thấy là gì? Thuận toán là
cái gì? Các bạn nhìn này. Cái hình này
ghi ở đây ghi là mô hình. Mô hình với cả
thuật toán nó khác nhau như thế nào các
bạn nhìn nhá. Hai cái điện này thuật
toán với mô hình khác nhau như nào?
Thuật toán nó là cái phương pháp, nó là
cái công thức. Được chưa? Nó là cái
phương pháp, nó là cái công thức. Còn mô
hình là sau khi các bạn áp dụng cái
thuật tuán đấy, áp dụng công thức đấy
vào một cái bộ dữ liệu cụ thể, tức là
các bạn dùng một cái bộ dữ liệu có cụ
thể, các bạn huấn luyện kế thuật toán
đấy, các bạn sẽ có cái mô hình đúng
không? Ví dụ thuật thuật toán là gì?
thực toán là cái phương pháp lái xe. Thế
bây giờ các bạn mà dựa vào cái phương
pháp này các bạn học cái phương pháp lái
xe này thì các bạn sẽ có cái gọi là mô
hình đúng không? Kỹ năng lái xe sau khi
các bạn học được chưa? Hoặc là các bạn
phương pháp giải toán chính là cái thuật
toán. Thế bây giờ sau khi các bạn tìm
hiểu cái cái phương pháp này rồi, các
bạn có cái khả năng các bạn tư duy rồi
thì đấy nó chính là mô hình. Tức là gì?
Từ một thuật toán các bạn có thể có rất
nhiều mô hình khác nhau. Được chưa? Từ
một thuật toán các bạn có thể có rất
nhiều mô hình khác nhau. Thuật toán là
cái thứ lý thuyết là cái khung. Sau khi
các bạn áp những cái bộ rượu khác nhau
vào cái khung này các bạn có sẽ có những
cái mô hình khác nhau. Được chưa? Cùng
là cái thuật toán đấy. Nhưng các bạn có
thể áp dụng thuật toán đấy để các bạn có
được một mô hình dự đán giá nhà. Các bạn
vẫn thuật toán đấy. Các bạn có thể có
được một mô hình dự đoán giá thị lợi.
Vẫn là cái mô hình đấy các bạn có thể có
mô mô hình dự đoán giá giá
xe ô ô tô chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đúng
không? Từ một thuật toán các bạn có thể
có nhiều mô hình dự đoán những thứ khác
nhau thì qua cái việc các bạn đưa nhiều
bộ dượu khác nhau vào. Được chưa?
Thế là cái sự thật toán và mô hình.
Nhưng mà thông thường thông thường khi
mà người ta nói về machining ấy thì
nhiều khi người ta cũng gọi hai từ này
nó cũng tương đương nhau. Tức là rất
nhiều khi người ta gọi lúc gọi là thuật
toán, lúc gọi là mô hình. Đấy. Thế nhưng
mà các bạn hiểu cái sự khác biệt cơ bản
là gì? Là thuật toán là cái thứ chung
chung tổng quát. Còn mô hình là cái thứ
cụ thể là khi mà tôi áp dụng thuật toàn
đấy vào một cái bộ rượu cụ thể rồi tôi
có cái mô hình được chưa? Cái mà chúng
ta sẽ học là thuật toán hôm nay. Cái
chúng ta sẽ học là thuậ là thuật toán
đến hôm thực hành chúng ta áp dụng thuật
toán chúng ta đưa một cái bộ rượu chúng
ta sử dụng thuật toán chúng ta huấn
luyện thì cái chúng ta kết thu được nó
là mô hình. Được chưa? Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Thì bây giờ nói về nói về nói về các cái
thuật toán thì ở đây chúng ta đang nói
chúng ta đang nói về machining và chúng
ta cụ thể chúng ta đang tập trung vào
supervide learning đúng không? học của
sát. Trong học của sát thì nó có hai bài
toán, hai bài toán chính là gì? Là
classification và reaction đúng không?
Thì bây gi chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau cho tìm
hiểu về các cái thuật toán được dùng cho
các cái bài toán này. Được chưa? Có
những thuật toán là chỉ dùng cho
classification, có những thuật toán là
chỉ dùng trong reation và có thật toán
nó dùng cho cả hai. Được chưa? Có ông là
dùng cho cả hai, có ông là cho mỗi
regression thôi, có mỗi ông là cho mỗi
classification thôi. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ nhá, bây giờ nhá, cậnh như
này, đầu tiên thuật toán đầu tiên chúng
ta cần tìm hiểu đó là linear regression.
Tứng nguyệt mình thì gọi là hồi quy
tuyến tính. Linear thì là tuyến tính,
regression thì là hồi quy. Đây có thể
được coi là một trong số những từ toán
cơ bản bậc nhất trong
machining. Gần như là ai học về
machining thì cũng sẽ phải học qua cái
thuật toán này. Được chưa? Cơ bản bậc
nhất. Rồi thế các bạn nhớ nhá. Cái ý
tưởng của tó toán linear reaction rất là
đơn giản. Các bạn nhìn cái tên của nó
này, nó là linear. Linear nghĩa là bậc
một đúng không? Thì đây ví dụ đây mình
có một cái ví dụ rất là cơ bản là gì?
Giả sử [âm nhạc] bây giờ tôi muốn xây
dựng một cái mô hình để tôi có thể giúp
tôi dự đoán được mức lương của một người
dựa vào số năm kinh nghiệm của anh ta.
Được chưa? Tôi muốn dự đoán mức lương
của một người dựa vào số năm kinh nghiệm
của anh ta. Tức là gì? Tức là bây giờ
với cái input là số năm kinh nghiệm, tôi
sẽ phải dự đoán được cái output là mức
lương của anh ta. Thế thì bây giờ ấy cái
th toán cơ bản nhất là gì? Là linear tức
là gì? Bây giờ các bạn tưởng tượng nhá,
các bạn sẽ có một cái bộ dữ liệu là bao
gồm những cái nhân viên của một công ty
đúng không? Với mỗi nhân viên này các
bạn sẽ có hai thông tin. Một là các bạn
sẽ có thông tin về số năm kinh nghiệm
của anh ta và hai là các bạn có thông
tin về mức lương của anh ta. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ mỗi một người này sẽ tương
đương với một cái điểm điểm màu vàng
này. Được chưa? Mỗi một người trong cái
bộ rượu này tương đương với một cái điểm
màu vàng này. Đúng không? Nếu các bạn
dóng từ cái điểm màu vàng này các bạn
dóng số trục hoành các bạn sẽ có chục sẽ
có số năm kinh nghiệm của anh ta. Còn
nếu các bạn dóng trục tung
các bạn sẽ có mức lương của anh ta. Được
chưa? Thì bây giờ cái
bây giờ cái nhiệm vụ của tôi là gì? Bây
giờ tôi sẽ phải làm sao? Tôi tìm được
một cái đường thẳng đi qua các cái điểm
này gần nhất có thể. Để làm sao? để sau
này nếu mà tôi có những người mới vào mà
tôi biết số năm kinh nghiệ của anh ta
thì tôi sẽ dùng cái đường thẳng này để
tôi dự đoán
mức lương của anh ta. Được chưa? Đây ví
dụ sau này trong tương lai các bạn có
một cái điểm mới này. Các bạn có thể dự
đoán xem là anh ta lương là bao nhiêu
đúng không? Thì các bạn nhìn này. Bây
giờ ấy tôi muốn làm như vậy thì các bạn
nhìn nhá. Tức là bây giờ tôi có một cái
bộ dữ liệu nó có rất nhiều sample nhưng
ở đây mình chỉ vẽ đại diện khoảng chục
cái như này thôi. Được chưa? Có những
sle này thì bây giờ nhiệm vụ tôi là tôi
phải tìm một cái đường thẳng đi qua các
cái điểm này. Tất nhiên là trong không
gian hai chiều này các bạn có thể vẽ
được vô số những cái đường thẳng như
này. Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta sẽ cần phải
tìm được một cái đường thẳng tốt nhất.
Đường thẳng tốt nhất là đường thẳng như
thế nào? Đường thẳng tốt nhất là cái
đường thẳng mà cái khoảng cách khoảng
cách trung bình giữa các cái điểm dựa
này đến đường thẳng nó phải là bé nhất.
Ví dụ nhá các bạn nhìn này. Ví dụ giả sử
đây là cái đường thẳng của tôi đúng
không? Đây là cái đường thẳng mà tôi tìm
ra. Được chưa? Tôi coi như đường này
được tốt nhất. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ ấy
các bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ có một người
mức lương ở đây đúng không? Có một người
ở đây đúng chưa? Số năm kinh nghiệm
chúng ta các bạn dòng số chục hoành được
chưa? Thế bây giờ đối với cái ông này
thì mô hình dự đoán lương của anh ta là
bao nhiêu? Thì muốn các bạn muốn biết
cái dự đoán các bạn muốn biết lương thực
tế nhá. Muốn biết lương thực tế các bạn
dòng song trụ tung này. Lương thực tế nó
ở dưới này. Được chưa? Còn mức lương mà
mình dự đoán ấy thì các bạn phải kẻ
vuông góc với trục hoành cắt cái đường
này ở đâu? Xong các bạn dóng trung tung
này. Được chưa? Đây là mức lương dự đoán
của mô hình. Còn dưới này là mức đường
thực tế đúng không? Đây này. Cái khoảng
cách từ cái điểm này đến đường thẳng đây
các bạn nh khoảng cách này này. Cái chỗ
chuột này này. Khoảng cách này nó chính
là cái sai lệch đúng không? Dưới này là
thực tế, trên này nó là dự đoán. Được
chưa? Thì với ông này với cái C1 này sai
số nó ở đây thì mình cũng sẽ tính sai số
như vậy với tất cả những điểm còn lại
thì cái đường thẳng tốt nhất là cái
đường thẳng mà cái trung bình sai số này
nó là bé nhất. Được chưa? Sau này có một
người mới mình chỉ biết số kinh nghiệm
của anh ta thôi. Mình muốn dự đoán được
mức lương thì bây giống
vuông góc với song song với trục tung
hoặc là vuông góc với trục hoành đúng
không? Cắt đường ở đâu? Cắt sang ngang
đây. Thì đây đây là mức lương mà chúng
ta dự đoán cho anh ta. Được chưa? Đây là
mức lương chúng ta dự đoán cho anh ta.
Đấy chính là cái ý tưởng của đây chính
là ý tưởng của linear reaction đúng
không? Cái đường thẳng mà chúng ta tìm
ra ấy nó phải là tối ư. Tối ưu tức là
gì? Tức là tổng khoảng cách hoặc là
trung bình khoảng cách. Tổng hay trung
bình đều được đúng không? Tổng hay trung
bình khoảng cách từ các cái điểm này đến
cái đường thẳng nó phải là bé nhất đúng
không? Các bạn sẽ vẽ được vô số các cái
đường khác nhưng chỉ có cái đường này là
đường tối hư thôi. Được chưa?
Thì đấy là ý tưởng của linear reaction
đúng không? Thì vì sao lại gọi là
linear? Tại vì nó là nó là tuyến tính
mà. Ngày xưa các bạn học phổ thông rồi
đúng không? Cái hàm tuyến tính ngày xưa
hàm bậc 1 ấy là hàm y = x + b. Thì các
bạn tưởng tượng và xem y chính là lương,
x chính là kinh nghiệm đúng không? Thì
bây giờ ấy y = ax + b thì nó là thuật
toán. Được chưa? y = ax + b thì nó là
thuật toán. Nhưng bây giờ sau khi các
bạn ốp dữ liệu vào trong mô hình đúng
không giả? Chúng ta huấn luyện một cách
nào đấy chúng ta ốp dữ liệu vào chúng ta
tìm ra được là gì? Là công thức là gì?
Là y = 3x + 4 đúng không? Thì y = ax + b
là thuật toán nhưng y = 3x + 4 lại là mô
hình. Đúng không? Chúng ta ốp dữ liệu
vào một cái đúng không? vào cái vào một
cái thuật toán thì kết quả chúng ta thu
được một cái lực mô hình đúng không? y =
ax + b là thuật toán. Trong trường hợp
chúng ta sử dụng mô hình dự đoán mức
lương thì y = 3x + 4 là mô hình nhưng
trong bài toán các bạn dự đoán giá thịt
lợn chẳng hạn thì y = 5x + 6 là mô hình
đúng không? Tức là gì? Từ một từ một
thuật toán các bạn dùng nhiều bộ rượu
khác nhau bạn huấn luyện thì nó sẽ có
nhiều cái mô hình khác nhau. Được chưa?
Đấy là cái ý tưởng của linear reaction.
Và chú ý là gì? là linear reion ấy. Cái
trường hợp đơn giản nhất là các bạn chỉ
có một biến đồ vào thôi. Nhưng trong
thực tế các bạn có thể có rất nhiều biến
đồ vào đúng không? Trong thấy các bạn có
thể rất nhiều biến đồ vào đây các bạn
nhìn đây đây là cái ví dụ giữa khác nhau
giữa thuật toán với cả mô hình này đúng
không? Lúc ban đầu công thức tổng quát
chỉ là y = x + b thôi đúng không? Ốp dữ
liệu vào rồi các bạn công thức đây ví dụ
y = 2 triệu nhân x cộng với 8 triệu đi
đúng không? Tức là mức lương gì? Bằng 2
triệu nhân số nă kinh nghiệm cộng với 8
triệu đúng không? Đấy sự khác biệt giữa
thuật toán và mô hình đấy. Được chưa?
Bên trái là tuật toán linear direction,
còn bên phải là mô hình linear
direction. Tuật toán là cái chung chung,
còn mô hình là cái cụ thể. Đúng chưa?
Rồi các bạn đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì
không?
Đến đây có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái thất toán này
ấy nó không chỉ có cái dạng này đâu. Đây
là cái hình thái cơ bản nhất của nó. Rồi
đây bây giờ mình sẽ nói về nhiều biến
đây. Đây là trường hợp các bạn chỉ có
một biến đầu vào thì dễ rồi nhưng khi
tôi có nhiều biến thì sao? Nhiều biến
thì tôi sẽ mở rộng ra thôi. Các bạn nhìn
nhá tổng quát là gì? y = w1x1 + w2x2 vân
vân cộng wpxp cộng w0 cộng vpsilon.
Silon nó là cái nhiễu nó là cái nó là
cái nó là cái nhiễu nó là cái thứ nó
khiến cho cái rượu ra nó không nằm đúng
trên cái đường thẳng ra hoặc là không
được đúng trên cái mặt phẳng. Các bạn
nhìn nhá. Bên trái là trường hợp các
bạn, bên trái là trường hợp các bạn chỉ
có một biến thôi. Một biến đổ vào là
kinh nghiệm thôi. Bên phải các bạn sẽ có
cả kinh nghiệm và cả học vấn nữa, đúng
không? Thì bên phải nó sẽ công thức nó
sẽ là gì? Nó sẽ là à ví dụ là z = ax +
by đúng không? Về mặt bản chất nó vẫn là
bậc 1 thôi mà đúng không? Bậc một của
cái trong không gian hai chiều là một
đường thẳng còn bậc một trong không gian
ba chiều là một mặt phẳng. Được chưa?
Bên trái là trong không gian hai chiều
cái cái cái cái Y của chúng ta ấy đúng
không? Nó là một đường thẳng. Còn bên
phải là không gian ba chiều thì cái Z nó
cái mặt phẳng như thế này. Được chưa?
Tất nhiên là các cái điểm ta sẽ không
nằm đúng trên cái đường thẳng vào mặt
phẳng này đâu. Nó sẽ lệch trên lịch
dưới. Nhưng mà tóm lại là gì? Tóm lại
thì đây là cái đường thẳng hoặc mặt
phẳng tối ưu nhất. Tại vì sao? Tại vì là
trung bình sai số của nó là hoặc là tổng
size số nó là bé nhất đúng không? So với
những cái đường thẳng hay là mặt phẳng
khác đúng không? Đây là trường hợp bên
phải là trường hợp hai biến. Còn các bạn
có ba bốn miến thì các bạn cứ mở rộng nó
như vậy thôi đúng không? Thì các bạn
thấy gì? Thấy là linear reaction ấy
chẳng qua nó là cái phiên bản mở rộng
của cái hàm bậc một mà ngày xưa chúng ta
học thôi đúng không? Ngày xưa các bạn
học ở phổ thông là bậc một là chỉ có một
biến đồ vào thôi. Còn bây giờ các bạn
lên đại học các bạn đi làm các thứ thì
các bạn sẽ gặp trường hợp là gì? Đầu vào
nó sẽ không phải có một biến đâu. Nó có
nhiều biến đúng không? Hai biến vẫn là
trường hợp đơn giản. Thực tế nó sẽ có
rất nhiều biến. Được chưa?
Linear được chưa? Cái trường hợp các bạn
chống một biến ấy, trong trường hợp
nhiều chiều thì sẽ là ma trận. Cái gì là
ma trận? Trong không gian nhiều chiều
thì sẽ là ma trận nhưng mà cái gì là ma
trận mới được. Đó các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái
trường hợp bên phải à trường hợp bên
trái ấ cái trường hợp bên trái là trường
hợp mà linear các bạn có một biến đồ vào
thôi. Có một feature một feature thôi
thì ta gọi là simple linear regression.
Còn bên phải là cái trường hợp mà các
bạn có 2 3 4 là các bạn có nhiều feature
đồ vào người ta sẽ gọi là multiple
linear reation. Được chưa?
Tất nhiên trong đấy các bạn sẽ có nhiều
biến nữa đúng không? Không chỉ có từng
này đâu. Đúng.
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Đường thẳng làm sao mà thành ma trận
được?
đường thẳng và ma trận nó có liên quan
đến nhau đâu.
Cái trường hợp bên phải này đi, bên phải
đ cái công thức của mặt phẳng này nó là
Z đúng không? Z là lương đi bằng ax + by
chẳng hạn đúng không? Nó có liên quan gì
đến ma trận đâu. Ma trận là một cái mảng
hai chiều mà toán này với hàm loss. Kế
thuật này và hàm los này nó nó chẳng
liên quan gì đến nhau cả. Cái thuật toán
này là cái nơi mà từ in những cái thuật
toán này ấ không siêu phẳng là trong cái
support vector machine cơ. Tí chúng ta
sẽ nói về hyperplane trong support
machine cơ. Đây chưa chưa chưa nói về
chỗ đấy.
Ờ thuật toán này là cái thứ mà giúp
chúng ta từ input ra được output tức là
gì? Input là cái dữ liệu đệ đồ vào và
giờ cái output là cái prediction cái dự
đoán của mô hình. Thì nó là cái thuật
toán đúng không? Thuật toán mô hình như
thế. Còn lot là gì? Lot là cái nó sẽ lấy
cái dự đoán của mô hình. So sánh với cái
giá trị thực tế để
ra được cái sai lệch đúng không? Thì đây
cái đoạn mà khi người ta huấn luyện mô
hình người ta lấy cái dự đoán của mô
hình bây giờ thầy có thể soanh cái thực
tế này nó chính là cái lót đấy đúng
không? Chính là cái lót đấy đúng không?
Cái mô hình này nó giống kiểu là các bạn
là người làm bài ấy các bạn làm bài từ
cái input đầu vào từ cái kinh nghiệm ra
các bạn ra được mức lương đúng không?
Đấy là các bạn ngồi làm bài là cái mô
hình này. Còn lot là cái thứ mà các bạn
dự đoán rồi. Cô giáo sẽ lấy cái dự đoán
các bạn soanh với thực tế để xem xe được
bao nhiêu rồi cô phê cô chấm vào đấy thì
đây chính là cái loss. Được chưa?
Rồi câu hỏi nhận không?
Trong không gian ba chiều thì các bạn sẽ
không gọi được cái tên của nó nữa. Trong
không gian ba chiều chúng chỉ gọi nó là
một cái thứ tuyến tính thôi. Còn cụ thể
hình như nào các bạn sẽ không hình dung
nữa. Tại vì là sao? Tại vì đơn giản là
chúng ta không vẽ được cái gì trong
không gian nhiều hơn đúng không? Các bạn
chỉ vẽ được không gian ba chiều là kịch
thôi. Trong không gian 4 năm chiều các
bạn hiểu một cách đơn giản nó là cái gì?
Nó tuyến tính thôi. Được chưa? Chúng ta
chỉ vẽ ở trong không gian đến đây đến ba
chiều là cực kim rồi đúng không? Trong
ba chiều này đã có một chiều là output
rồi, ta chỉ có hai chiều là input thôi.
Đúng không? Vẽ này là hết hết mức rồi.
Không gian nhiều hơn nữa thì các bạn chỉ
hiểu nó là một cái gì nó b nó tuyến tính
thôi. Tuyến tính của nhiều biến thế
thôi. Còn bây giờ chúng ta sẽ không gọi
nó là đường hay là mặt đúng không? Chúng
ta chỉ quan châm là cái tính chất của nó
là gì. Còn cụ thể cái hình nó như nào
thì nó không quá quan trọng. Đấy nó vẫn
bằc 1 đúng không? Bên trái là y = ax + b
còn bên phải là z = ax + by đúng không?
Và cộng ax + by + c đúng không? Tóm lại
nó là một cái gì nó tuyến tính bậc một
thôi.
100 chiều hay 1000 chiều nó vẫn cứ lập
bậc một.
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không
nhá? Thì đây gọi là linear reaction. Đây
là một trong số t toán cơ bản và đơn
giản bậc nhất trong machining mà gần như
là ai học về machining cũng sẽ phải học
cái tọt toán này. Được chưa? Linear
nhớ nhá là nó dành cho bài toán hồi quy.
Được chưa? Dành cho bài toán hồi quy. À
nói cái từ hồi quy một chút các bạn nhá.
Ờ nếu như bạn nào các bạn học machining,
các bạn đọc tài liệu bằng tiếng Anh thì
sao nhá. Nếu các bạn đọc tài liệu về
machining bằng tiếng Anh thì sao. Nhưng
nếu các bạn đọc tài liệu bằng tiếng Việt
ấy thì có một cái điểm các bạn cần phải
chú ý với cái từ re này. Được chưa? Với
từ reaction tức là gì? Tức là
khi mà người ta dịch từ tiếng a dịch từ
tiếng Anh sang tiếng Việt ấy có hai cái
từ hai cái từ mà
có hai cái từ mà
ý nghĩa của nhó hoàn toàn khác biệt nhau
nó chả liên quan gì đến nhau nhưng mà
người ta lại dịch ra cùng một dịch ra
cùng một nghĩa có hai cái từ một là
regression cái mà bạn vừa nhìn thấy ấy
đấy regression tiếng Việt mình gọi là
hồi Q
thôi Q đúng không? Nó chỉ đơn giản là
cái bài toán và cái output đầu ra là cái
giá trị liên tục. Được chưa?
Thế còn sau này bạn nào các bạn học tiếp
về deing. Ví dụ bạn nào học về khóa sau
ấ học về deing các bạn sẽ có một cái
khái niệm là gì? Là recurrent.
Recurrent. Và vì một cái lý do gì đấy
mình cũng không biết lý do gì mà người
ta cũng dịch sang cũng là hồi quy mặc dù
hai từ này nó chả liên quan gì đến nhau.
Thế thì requent này các bạn sẽ gặp trong
cái trường hợp là mạng neuron hồi quy
new network là cái kiến trúc mà ngày xưa
ấy trước khi mà Transformer cái mô hình
ngốn ngấn đầu tiên ra đời ấy thì trước
2018 trước 2017 ấy thì đây là kiến trúc
requ new network là kiến trúc rất là phổ
biến để xử lý cho dữ liệu dạng văn bản
nhưng mà bây giờ người ta ít người ta
người ta gần như người ta rất là ít khi
người ta dùng nó thế nhưng mà hai từ này
nói chung là nó chả liên quan đến nhau
cả nhưng mà dưới tiếng Việt người ta cứ
dịch chung là thành hồi qu linear
reaction thì là hồi quy tuyến tính
recurrent new network gọi là mạng non
hồi
Thế muốn giả sử các bạn đọc đọc th tiếng
Việt ấy các bạn muốn biết nó là cái từ
nào thì các bạn phải đọc cả cái ngữ cảnh
của nó xem các cái từ xung quanh nó thì
các bạn mới biết nó từ nào cho các bạn
chỉ dựa vào mỗi từ này thôi các bạn chịu
không biết là cái từ hồi quy người ta
nói là về cái gì đâu được chưa nhá các
bạn học bằng tiếng Anh thì không lo
tiếng Anh thì hai từ này nó hai từ khác
nhau sẵn rồi còn bạn nào đọc th bằng
tiếng Việt thì các bạn chú ýế này
sau này có nhiều tài liệu bằng tiếng
Việt ấy để cho người đọc đỡ bị nhầm lẫn
thì người ta có cái xuống ta dịch từ thứ
hai này người ta dịch là hồi tiếp nó sẽ
đỡ bị nhầm hơn hồi tiếp.
Hồi tiếp đấy thì nó sẽ bị nhầm hơn nhưng
mà rất nhiều tài liệu nó vẫn dùng cái
gọi là hồi quy như này được chưa nhá.
Rồi tiếp nhá.
Rồi các bạn như này thế trước khi nghỉ
giải lao chúng ta nói qua m chút về một
vài những cái ưu điểm cũng như là nhược
điểm của linear reaction. Đây về mặt bản
chất là một là một thật toán nó vô cùng
đơn giản. Nó rất rất đơn giản và nó chỉ
tập trung khai thác vào mối quan hệ
tuyến tính mà thôi.
Thì cái thoán này nó sẽ rất phù hợp với
những cái bộ dữ liệu tuyến tính. Bộ rượu
tuyến tính là bộ rượu gì? Bữa trước
chúng ta nói rồi. Bộ rượu tuyến tính là
bộ dữ liệu mà có một hoặc là một vài
những cái feature có hệ số tương quan
lớn với cả tit. Được chưa? Một bộ dữ
liệu mà có một hoặc là một vài những cái
feature có hệ số tương quan lớn với cả
target thì những cái bộ rượu vậy nó sẽ
cực kỳ phù hợp với th toán này. Được
chưa? Cực kỳ phù hợp với linear reation.
Đấy cái mồi này nó sẽ đặc biệt phù hợp
với những bộ dữ liệu như vậy. Bộ dữ liệu
có một và một vài feature có hệ số thông
qua đơn với Tit.
Thế ngoài ra thì này nó còn có một cái
ưu điểm nữa là gì? Là khả năng giải
thích cao. Khả năng giải thích có nghĩa
là gì? Tức là ấy chúng ta sau khi mà mô
hình nó đưa dự đoán rồi chúng ta muốn
quay ngược lại chúng ta muốn giải thích
là gì? Là trong cái feature đầu vào cái
feature nào nó có ảnh hưởng lớn đến tit
feature nào ảnh hưởng lớn feature nào
ảnh hưởng ít đúng không? Thì ví dụ các
bạn nhìn này cái mức tưởng phát này đúng
không? y = w1x1 + w22 vân cộng đến w3x3
+ wpxp cộng w0 các thứ này đúng không?
Chúng ta có các cái biến đồ vào là x1 x2
vân đến xp à w đồ vào là w1 w2 vân đến
wp này đúng không? Thế bây giờ ấy sau
khi mố hình mình nó dự đoán là ra cái y
rồi đúng không? Bây giờ tôi muốn quay
ngược lại tôi giải thích xem là x1 x2 x3
xp ông nào là ông quan trọng nhất trong
việc đưa dự đoán của tôi thì tôi làm thế
nào các bạn nhỉ? Tôi muốn biết là trong
cái input đồ vào này ông nào là ông quan
trọng nhất thì tôi làm thế nào? Th dựa
vào cái gì?
Dựa vào cái gì bây giờ?
Dựa vào cái gì?
Đúng rồi. So hệ số omega đúng không? Ông
nào có cái trị tuyệt đối đúng không? Cái
W này đúng không? W này các bạn. Ông nào
có cái trị tuyệt đối này nó càng lớn thì
ờ cái trị tuyệt đối nó càng lớn thì nó
càng quan trọng đúng không? Trị tuyệt
đối nhá chứ không phải là giá trị đúng
không? Âm cũng được. Giá trị tuyệt đối
nó càng lớn thì nó càng ảnh hưởng nhiều
đến cái target của chúng ta đúng không?
Thì đây toàn toàn nó rất là dễ giải
thích. Tôi quay ngượ lại tôi ngay. Ví dụ
là tôi sử dụng một cái mô hình dự án giá
nhà dựa vào ờ số tầng, dựa vào diện
tích, dựa vào vị trí đúng không? Tôi y =
w11, w2 w3 cộng w0. Thì bây giờ tí nữa
tôi quay lại tôi giải thích xem là
cái tác nhân nào, cái thông tin nào là
cái thông tin nó ảnh hưởng nhều nhất đến
cái tí của tôi. Giá nhà thì tôi xem là
cái hệ số đi cùng với cả số tầng, diện
tích với cả vị trí thì ông nào là ông có
trị tuổi lớn nhất thì là ông ảnh hưởng
nhiều nhất thôi đúng không? Thế thì
linear re là cái một cái thật toán nó
rất mạnh về cái độ giải thích. Nó nó
thán nó rất là đơn giản nhưng nó lại rất
là mạnh về độ giải thích. Được chưa? Thế
nhưng mà nó cũng có một vài những cái
nhược điểm. Nhược điểm đây là gì? Nhược
điểm ở đây là nó rất là rất là nhạy cảm
về out layer. Outlayer là cái gì? Out
layer là những cái điểm mà là những cái
điểm mà nó khác biệt với những cái điểm
còn lại. Các bạn tưởng tượng nhá cái
linear trên này đúng không? Bây tôi có
một cái điểm nó ở tít dưới này đúng
không? một cái điểm nở tít thế này. Cái
điểm này nó sẽ khiến cho cái loss nó rất
là lớn. Tại vì là cái với cái đường
thẳng này đúng cái dự đoán nó sẽ rất là
sai, rất là nhiều. Thì bây giờ để cho
khi mà mình nó tối ưu mà có một cái điểm
dưới này nó sẽ phải ra nó chệch cái
đường này nó đi xuống dưới. Tức là gì?
Chỉ vì một cái điểm AL này nó sẽ khiến
cho mô hình nó sẽ phải hy sinh cái sự
cái sự tập trung vào những cái điểm khác
đúng không? Thì đấy là cái to đán lin
này cái phiên bản gốc của nó thì nó cực
kỳ nhạy cảm cái out layer. Chỉ cần có
một hai cái outayer thôi nó sẽ khiến cho
mô hình nó tồ đi rất là nhiều. Đó nó
khiến cho mình là để cái giảm cái size
số với AL nó sẽ phải hy sinh rất nhiều
size số cho những cái điểm bình thường
khác. Được chưa? Rất dễ bị ảnh hưởng bởi
đa cộng tuyến tại vì là bản thân nó là
nó khai thác một hệ bậc một mà đa cộng
tuyến cũng liên quan đến bậc một đúng
không nó rất dễ bị ảnh hưởng về outlayer
à bởi bởi đa cộng tuyến. Thế và nếu mà
cái bộ rượu các bạn ấy nó chẳng có cái
feature nào có hệ số tương quan lớn với
Tit. Hệ số tương quan lớn đây nhưng mình
nhắc nhắc lại nhá là gì? Là gần 1 hoặc
là gần -1 được chưa? Thì nếu mà cái bộ
rượu mà chẳng có cái fion nào có hệ số
tương quan lớn với tit cả thì
thông thường cái thuật toán này nó sẽ
không không quá hiệu quả. Được chưa? Nó
chỉ mạnh về m hệ tuyến tính thôi. Còn
nếu bộ dữ liệu mà không có phí nào có hệ
số tương quán lớn với tác ít không có mệ
tế tính thì tầm n thường nó sẽ ra kết
quả rất là thấp.
Được chưa? Đấy là những cái ưu điểm cũng
như là nhược điểm của linear.
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không? Có
bạn nào có tắc mắc gì không?
Chúng ta nghỉ giá 5 phút nhá. Được
không? Nghỉ giút nhá. Chúng mình sẽ phép
một ch này.
>> À xin lỗi thầy cho mình hỏi với các bạn
ở trong này một tí. Ờ
có bạn nào học về chuyên toán không thì
có thể cho mình xin contact một ít được
không? À tại vì mình có chắc làị
[tiếng cười] có con đang muốn học thêm
về toán nên muốn liên hệ với các bạn mà
chuyên toán để biết về
có thầy cô dạy chuyên về toán và luyện
thi. Thì
không biết là có thể
con chị học lớp 6 em ạ. 12 tuổi
và bạn ấy
ở bên ở bên Mỹ. Vâng.
>> Nhưng mà chị muốn cũng đi thi toán nhưng
mà cũng muốn là luyện thêm về toán tại
vì thấy các bạn toán ở Châu Á mình có vẻ
giỏi hơn. [tiếng cười]
À ờ thì không biết là chị xin lỗi hỏi
bài bài phô thế thì có về contact thì
nếu như mà chị để contact của chị ở đây
nhá. Ờ nếu như bạn nào mà
thấy thì tin nhị về email nhá. Cảm ơn
mọi người.
Ừ thì thì cứ contact với cả chị về cái
email này nhá. Cảm ơn mọi người. Tại v
thấy nhiều bạn trong này có phải học
chuyên toán và cũng có nền tảng với
toán. Cảm ơn mọi người nhá.
Mọi người cứ cứ thoải mái trao đổi nhá.
Thoải mái trao đổi nhá. Thầy hỏi một câu
được không? Ơ đi em hỏi đi hỏi thoải
mái.
>> Như thầy nói là cái
hồi quy này ấ nó rất là nhạy cảm với
outlier ấy.
>> Dạ.
>> Thì thông thường ví dụ trong các bài
toán y tế nhá thì các cái giá trị xét
nghiệm ấy mà gợi ý mà bệnh ác tính ấ
thường nó sẽ rất là khác biệt.
>> Thế thì theo như thầy thì các cái bài
toán đấy thì phải giải quyết bằng cách
nào ạ?
Nhưng mà thế này trong cái trường hợp
đấy tức là trong cái trường hợp của mình
ấy thì những cái out đấy là những cái
thứ mà mình lại muốn quan tâm đúng
không?
>> Tức là nó khác như này nhá. Tức là ví dụ
như mình nói chu ví dụ mình sử dụng cái
mô hình dự án mức lương đi đúng không?
Thì mình muốn là cái mô hình này nó đúng
với phần lớn người lao động chứ còn ví
dụ trong công ty tiên có con của sếp
chẳng hạn chả có kinh nghiệm gì nhưng mà
lương rất là cao thì mình không muốn là
cái mùi nó bị ảnh hưởng bởi những cái
chỗ đấy. Thì lúc ấy mình nói là tức là
đấy là cái nhược điểm nó nó bị ảnh hưởng
bởi out layer. Thế còn trường hợp của
mình với là trả nói về y tế đúng không?
Tức là những cái người mà bị bệnh ấy là
những người mà thật ra về bản chất thì
họ chính là outlayer. Nhưng mà đấy là
cái trường hợp chúng ta lại muốn mô hình
tập trung vào đấy thì lúc ấy thì dùng mô
hình này nó không có vấn đề gì cả. Nhưng
mà chúng ta chỉ dùng khi nào mà chúng ta
có một và một vài những cái feature nó
có cái hệ số tương quan lớn thôi thì
mình nên dùng. Còn nếu mà không thì mình
sẽ phải dùng mô hình phi tuyến mô hình
nó phức tạp hơn.
Tức là cái việc mà mô hình nó tập trung
vào outer ấy không phải lúc nào cũng
tổi. Trong phần lớn trường hợp nó là tổ
nhưng mà những trường hợp nào mà đấy là
cái thứ mà chúng ta muốn thì chúng ta cứ
dùng thôi. Chả vấn đề gì cả.
Vâng nhá. Bạn nào các bạn muốn hỏi thì
các bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
Thưa thầy, nãy thầy đưa ra một cái show
ra một cái công thức ấy, nó có rất nhiều
cái hệ số beta ấ dàng dạc như thế. Em
hiểu là có phải nó có rất nhiều các đặc
điểm để mình đưa vào đúng không thầy?
>> Biến kiểu biến số ấy.
>> Thế cái này đúng không? Trang này đúng
không?
Này trang nào nhỉ? À không đúng rồi
nhưng à em v em nhầm nó vẫn là nó vẫn là
x thôi nó không phải là cái giá trị khác
>> ừ nó in nhiều vào ví dụ x1 thì là học
vấn x2 là kinh nghiệm x3 là cái gì đấy
nó có giải này giải kia hay không kiểu
kiểu như vậy tức là chúng ta tức là
chúng ta đưa dự đoán tôi sẽ có nhiều
thông tin đầu vào hơn
>> tức là vậy em hỏi em hỏi vậy thì em hỏi
chỗ này
>> ừ
>> trong trường hợp mà mình có rất nhiều
biến đầu vào ví dụ kinh nghiệm nàyụ giới
tính này ờ tuổi tác này
>> ví dụ các cái network khác nữa ví dụ nó
có hàng ví dụ mấy chục cái cái feature
đi.
>> Dạ.
>> Thì
mình làm sao mà mình biết được là những
cái nào là cái quan trọng thấy tức là
mình có chắc chắn là sẽ không đưa hết
vào rồi.
>> Đúng rồi. Tức là này ờ sau này đến buổi
chụ hành chúng ta sẽ có một cái khái
niệm người ta gọi là giảm chiều dữ liệu.
Giảm chiều dữ liệu có nghĩa gì? Tức là
bây gi lại, tôi chỉ dùng một cái tập con
thôi. Đấy thì nhưng mà muốn giảm chiều
dữ liệu nó phải tùy thuật toán. Mỗi
thuật toán nó sẽ có cách giảm chiếu khác
nhau. Ờ ví dụ trong toán này nó sẽ có
một cái khái niệm người ta gọi là ờ gọi
là tiếng Việt. Mình huết tiếng Việt gọi
là gì? trong tiếng Anh người ta là
regularization thì nó sẽ tự động sẽ nó
sẽ những cái những cái feature nào mà nó
mà nó ít quan trọng ấy nó sẽ có cách để
người ta co cái hệ số về không mà khi hệ
số về 0 rồi thì coi như là nó chả đóng
góp gì nữa. Đấy là cách để người ta có
thể người ta giảm bớt số lượng feature
đi.
>> Vâng.
>> Ừ thưa thầy nếu vậy sẽ xảy ra một tình
huống là có một cái feature nào đấy mà
mình nghĩ là nó quan trọng nhưng mà sau
khi giảm chiều dố liệu thì nó biến mất.
>> Đúng rồi. C cũng có vẻ như thế. Tại vì
là
nếu nếu mà chúng ta nếu mà chúng ta nghĩ
nó quan trọng, nếu chúng ta tin chắc nó
quan trọng mà cái thậ toàn nó vô tình nó
giảm đi thì chúng ta chúng ta có thể
chúng ta sẽ để nó riêng ra ngoài, chúng
ta sẽ không cho nó tham gia vào và vào
quá trình chọn lọc nữa. Thế nhưng mà có
một cái đó là gì? Đó là cách chúng ta
nhìn dữ liệu và cách mô hình nhìn dữ
liệu nó sẽ có sự khác nhau. Tức là có
thể tại vì là ờ suy cho cùng cái thứ mà
chúng ta đang muốn ờ thứ mà chúng ta
đang muốn thứ mà chúng ta đang muốn ờ
tức là cái cái đối tượng mà đang làm
việc với dữ liệu là mô hình chứ không
phải chúng ta. Nhiều khi cái mô hình nó
sẽ có cái góc nhìn nó khác với chúng ta.
Thế nhưng mà cũng không phải lo lắm tại
vì là nó có rất nhiều những cái phương
pháp mà để mình có thể tức là mình dùng
tức là dùng dùng gọi là dùng dùng
statistic để mình đánh giá cái tầm quan
trọng nên là mình cũng thường là mình
cũng không phải dùng không phải không
không phải làm thủ công mấy đâu cũng
phải làm thủ công mấy trừ phi là có
những cái có những cái feature mà có
những cái feature mà
tôi biết chắc chắn là nó chảy ví dụ tôi
biết chắc chắn là là nó nó nó quan trọng
nó ảnh hưởng thì tôi sẽ để nguyên nó ra
tôi sẽ không cho nó tham gia vào quá
trình chúng ta giảm giảm xu nữa. Thế còn
có những ph nào tôi biết chắc chắn là
tôi không nó không quan trọng một chút
nào tôi sẽ bỏ nó luôn còn không tôi sẽ
dùng cái thống kê để tôi xem là feature
nào nó quan trọng nhá đến khoảng chúng
ta thực hành được khoảng ba buổi sau
chúng ta sẽ nói về cái phần liên quan
đến cho lọ cho lọ gọi là gì nhở giảm
chiều dữ liệu nhá giảm chiều dữ liệu thì
chúng ta sẽ có cách để chúng ta có thể
chúng ta giảm bớt số lượng feature này
đi.
Tiếp các bạn nhá. Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá.
Tiếp nhá.
Ờ Zalo sau khi sau khi add xong ấy thì
nó cũng không hiện số đâu các bạn. Các
bạn có thể bạn nào các bạn muốn trao rồi
các bạn có thể p thẳng số Zalo vào đây
này. Mọi người add cho dễ. Pết thẳng vào
đây này. Còn Zalo add xong mình cũng
không có nhìn được số của người khác.
Các bạn add thẳng vào đây xong. Đây là
dễ nhất. Đ tiếp nhá. Các bạn nhìn này.
Vừa rồi mình vừa nói về linear reaction
đúng không? Mình nói lại gì? Linear
reaction là một cái thuật toán nó sẽ
khai thác mối quan hệ bậc một đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà nó sẽ chỉ phù hợp
với trường hợp mà rượu các bạn nó rất là
đơn giản thôi đúng không các bạn? Tưởng
tượng này với cái trường hợp mà rượu các
bạn cái các bạn nhớ cái gọi là cái khuôn
mẫu của rượu bạn nhìn nó phức tạp hơn
như này đúng không? Nó rất phức tạp này
thì nếu chúng ta cứ cố gắng chúng ta cố
đấm ăn xôi, chúng ta vẽ một cái đường
thẳng đi qua những cái điểm này thì nhìn
chung là nó sẽ không tốt đúng không?
Nhìn chung trong trường hợp này các bạn
có vẽ một đường thẳng các bạn vẽ kiểu
rời thì nó cũng không thể tốt được đúng
không? Trong trường hợp này tôi sẽ cần
có những cái trường hợp tôi sẽ cần có
những cái thằng nó phức tạp hơn đúng
không? Ví dụ bậc một là đơn giản tôi
phức tạp hơn. Tôi sẽ có bậc hai bậc 3,
bậc 4 chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đúng
không? Thì đấy là cái trường hợp của cái
hàm người ta gọi là polynomial reaction.
Linear thì là thì là bằng một tuyến tính
đúng không? Còn polynomial tiếng Việt
mình gọi là đa thức đấy. Ho quy đa thức
đúng không? Thì bây giờ các bạn thấy là
bây giờ vẫn đầu vào các bạn chỉ có một
một biến x thôi nhưng mà các bạn sẽ gọi
là có không chỉ có tuyến tính nữa, không
phải bông một nữa. Có cả bậc hai, bậc 3,
bậc 4 v bậc n không?
Cái hình của các bạn nhìn đây theo các
bạn nó tối thiểu phải là bậc mấy các
bạn? Cái đường màu xanh này tối thiểu nó
phải là bậc mấy?
Cái đường màu xanh này tối thiểu bằng
mấy các bạn?
>> Bậc 3.
>> Đúng rồi. Tối bậc 3 đúng không? Tối bậc
3 đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà với polynomal nó lại có một
cái nó có một cái vấn đề các bạn ạ. Nó
có một cái vấn đề đó là
lúc trước ấy là tôi chỉ có bậc một thôi
thì nó dễ rồi. Nhưng bây giờ của tôi là
gì? Là bậc. Thật ra là thật ra là linear
reaction nó là một cái trường hợp riêng
của polynomial nhá. Tức là khi mà bậc
cao nhất nó bằng 1 đúng không? Khi bậc
cao nhất bằng 1 thì thì
polynomial nó chính là linear luôn đúng
không? Nhưng mà nhìn chung ấy khi mà nói
về polynomial tức là ý người ta đang
muốn nói là trên m tức là có thể 2 3 4
nhưng mà vấn đề bây giờ trên 1 thì là
bao nhiêu bây giờ đúng không? 2 bậc ha
thì cũng là trên 1 bậc 3 là trên 1 bậc 4
là trên 1 đúng không? [khịt mũi]
Vì sao tại quan tâm được đấy? Tại vì như
này sau này các bạn sẽ học là gì? thì
chúng ta sẽ phải cân bằng giữa cái độ
chính xác của mô hình và cái độ phức tạp
của mô hình. Chúng ta muốn mô hình càng
chính xác thì càng tốt nhưng đồng thời
chúng ta cũng muốn mô hình nó không quá
phức tạp nhá. Chúng ta cũng muốn mô hình
nó không quá phức tạp.
Không quá phức tạp. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
nếu mô hình phức tạp nó sẽ dẫn đến một
cái hiện tượng rất là phổ biến trong
machining mà chắc chắn các bạn sẽ nghe
rất là nhiều. Đó là hiện tượng là
overfitting. Overfitting tức là khi mà
khi mà thuật toán thì phức tạp trong khi
dữ liệu này đơn giản. Cái độ phức tạp
của mô hình nó vượt quá độ phức tạp của
thật toán nó vượt quá nhiều so với dữ
liệu thì các bạn sẽ bị overfitting. Over
fitting các bạn tưởng tượng ví dụ bây
cái hình này nhá. Bây giờ các bạn mà
dùng đây hàm bậc 3 như này đúng không?
Vâ các bạn dùng hàm bậc 300 đi đúng
không? Nó sẽ lồi lên lồi xuống nó sẽ rất
là zắ. Thì cái đường như vậy trong tương
lai nó sẽ rất là dễ nó bị sai đúng
không? Thế nên là khi mà với cái hàm đại
với cái hối quý đa thức này chúng ta lại
phải có một cái bài toán là gì? Làm sao
để tôi có thể tôi dùng một cái hàm nó
càng đơn giản thì càng tốt đúng không?
Bậc nó càng thấp thì càng tốt nhưng mà
nó vẫn phải đi qua các cái điểm dữ liệu
này tốt nhất có thể. chưa? Cái này mình
sẽ nói ở cái phần sau khi chúng ta nói
về liên quan đến chính quy hóa cho cho
dữ liệu nhá. Polynomial reion tất nhiên
các bạn nghe tên các bạn biết rồi. Đây
là một hàm theo cái trường phái là phi
tuyến đúng không? Nó là một hàm nó sẽ
phù hợp với trường hợp dượ bạn là phi
tuyến chứ trường hợp dữ liệu tuyến tính
người ta không dùng cái hàm này. Thế
nhưng mà cái hàm này thì thật ra nó cũng
không dùng không dùng tức là nó phổ biến
nhưng mà dùng không có quá là nhiều. Tại
vì là khi mà nói về những cái phàm à
những cái mô hình phi tuyến ấy thì có
rất là nhiều sự lựa chọn khác chứ không
chỉ có polynomal và nhiều lựa chọn khác
nó tốt hơn cái cái polynomial này. Được
chưa? Thế nhưng mà đây chúng ta cũng nói
qua để chúng ta biết đúng không? Line là
bậc 1 thì sẽ có polynomial là bậc 1, bậc
2 bậc 3 4 b n vân vân đúng không? Đấy,
nói qua một tí cái này nó là cái size nó
là cái size số tức là nó là cái những
cái nhiễu nhiễu này là những cái thứ nó
khiến cho rượu ra nó không nằm nằm đúng
trên một đường thẳng đúng không? Kiểu gì
nó phải lệch lên lệch lệch xuống bạn
hiểu cái nô na như vậy. Tại vì nếu mà
không có nhiễu này thì tất cả phải làm
đúng trên một đường thẳng đúng không?
Trong thực tế là sẽ không m có chuyện
đấy cả đúng không? Hai ông cùng số năm
kinh nghiệm nhưng mà kiểu gì có để mức
lương nó sẽ không thể bằng nhau hoàn
toàn đúng không? Thì mô hình bao giờ nó
cũng sẽ có những cái sai lệch như vậy.
Được chưa? Đấy. Thế đây là linear
reaction và polynomial. Được chưa?
>> [khịt mũi]
>> Thế thì các bạn nhìn này, tiếp này. Vừa
nãy giờ ấy là chúng ta chỉ nói về bài
toán re thôi. Được chưa? Nãy giờ chúng
ta chỉ nói về bài toán re thôi. Thế
nhưng mà bây giờ chúng ta hãy thử nói về
bài toán classification đi. Thế bây gi
các bạn nhìn này. Bây giờ nếu chúng ta
đang có một cái thuật toán dành cho bài
toán chúng ta đang có linear reaction
chẳng hạn đúng không? Chúng ta đang có
linear reaction. Bây câu hỏi là gì? Là
làm sao để tôi có thể tôi biến tấu cái
thuật toán linear re này đang từ thuật
toán dành cho bài toán hồi quy làm sao
để tôi có thể biến nó thành thuật toán
dành cho bài toán phân loại. Bây giờ thì
đầu tiên ấy chúng ta muốn biến nó chúng
ta phải nhìn xem một chút vào cái tính
chất của nó. Các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá.
Về mặt tổng quát không nói cụ thể là bài
toán dự đoán lương hay là dự đoán nhà
giá nhà. Mình nhớ một bài toán tổng quát
thôi. Các bạn cho mình hỏi là với một
cái mô hình linear reaction, các bạn cho
mình hỏi cái giải giá trị mà cái mô hình
này nó có thể dự đoán. Tức là cái đầu ra
đấy, cái y đấy đúng không? Cái giải giá
trị của y nó nằm trong khoảng từ bao
nhiêu đến bao nhiêu?
Cái giải giá trị của y nằm trong khoảng
từ bao nhiêu đến bao nhiêu hả các bạn?
Cái giải giá trị đầu ra của y nằm trong
khoảng từ bao nhiêu đến bao nhiêu? Đúng
rồi, từ âm vô cùng đến dương vô cùng
đúng không? Tức là bây giờ ấy cái đồ ra
của linear direction đang là từ âm vô
cùng đến dương vô cùng. Nhưng mà bây giờ
với bài toán phân loại đi, ví dụ ch bài
toán đơn giản đi là bài toán binary
classification đi đúng không? Binary
classification các bạn chỉ có hai class
thôi được không? Các bạn chỉ có hai
class thôi. Thế bây giờ cái bài toán tôi
là gì? Với bài toán phân loại, tôi chỉ
có hai class thôi. Làm sao để tôi có thể
ánh xạ một cái số y này đang nằm trong
khoảng từ âm vô cùng đến dương v cùng.
Làm sao tôi có thể ánh xạ nó sang một
cái gì đấy để tôi có thể đưa vào một là
class số 0, hai là class số 1 đúng
không? Làm sao để tôi có thể ánh xạ một
cái thứ đang nằm trong khoảng từ âm vô
cùng đến dương vô cùng thành một cái thứ
mà tôi có thể tôi converse xem là nó
thuộc class số 0 hay class số 1. Bây giờ
đúng ví dụ mình có bài toán binary vậy
chỉ có hai class thôi đúng không? Mình
quý là một class số 0 một class số 1
đúng không? Thế bây giờ cách người ta
làm là gì? Là bây giờ ấy sau khi cái dữ
liệu đồ vào của tôi ấy đúng không? Ví dụ
bây giờ các bạn thay vì các bạn đang dự
đoán mô hình giữa bức lương các bạn muốn
sử cái mô hình để dự đoán xem là dự đoán
xem là gì? Là một người là lương cao hay
là lương thấp chẳng hạn. Đó các bạn chỉ
có hai class thôi. Lương cao với lương
lương thấp đúng không? Chỉ có hai class
vậy thôi. Thì bây gi tôi phải làm thế
nào? Làm sao để tôi làm được như vậy?
Thì bây giờ người ta sẽ dùng cái hàm hàm
này người ta gọi là hàm sigmil.
Hàm này gọi là hàm xo các bạn nhìn nhá.
Đây ví dụ đây đúng không? Ví dụ đây tôi
tôi có một cái bài toán phân loại thì
bây gi m bất kinh nghiệm tôi dự đán xem
là một người là junio hay là senior đúng
không? Junior là class số 0 sino là
class số 1. Thế bây giờ các bạn ông các
cái điểm nó sẽ rơi vào như này đúng
không? Ông nào mà kinh nghiệm là cái
trục hoành trình độ là trục tung nó nó
chỉ có trục tung nó chỉ có hai giá trị
này thôi. Các bạn dùng cái mô hình
linear này các bạn có vẽ kiểu rời nó
cũng không thể tốt được đúng không? Vẽ
kiểu gì cũng không thể tốt được đúng
không? Nó sẽ fail ngay. Thế bây gi cách
phải làm gì? Thì là bây giờ ta sẽ dùng
một cái hàm hàm này được gọi là hàm
xmoid. Hàm này sau này bạn nào học tiếp
đến khóa trên các bạn học về deep
learning các bạn sẽ lại gặp lại cái hàm
này một lần nữa. Trong deep learning hàm
này người ta gọi là hàm kích hoạt hay là
activation function nhưng mà thôi tạm
thời đây các bạn sẽ dùng nó như này.
Được chưa? Cái hàm xin đặc điểm như này
các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái đồ thị này nó có
đặc điểm gì ở đây nhá. Ở đây đúng không
các bạn? Nhìn thấy ở chỗ này này đúng
không? Đây là ờ trục hoành là x đúng
không? Trục tung là y đúng không? Thế
còn ở đây ấ thì thì
thật ra là trục hoành nó đang là i tức
là gì? Trục hoành nó là cái output của
cái mô hình linear re còn trục tung bây
giờ nó là cái output mới được cho bài
toán classification. Được chưa các bạn?
Nhìn này. Tức là cái hàm sig công thức
là gì? Nếu input là m thì output sẽ bằng
1 chia cho 1 + e mũ trừ m. Thế nhưng mà
ở đây cái input của chúng ta nó chính là
cái output của mô hình linear direction
mà linear direction nó là y = x + b đúng
không? Thì bây giờ output sẽ là 1 chia
cho 1 cộng với e của trừ ax + b. Tức là
đây chính là cái y này đúng không? Y này
tức là kiểu kiểu như này hiểu này nhá.
Tức như này. Lúc ban đầu chúng ta có
input đầu vào là x nhá. Đúng không? X
này. Được chưa? X này các bạn đưa qua
linear
linear regression
đúng không? Reation các bạn ra được i.
Được chưa? Bây giờ I các bạn cho nó đi
qua cái hàm sig.
sigmo đúng không? Input là y mà thì
output sẽ là 1 chia 1 + e mũ trừ y thế
thôi đúng không? Và y trong trường hợp
này của chúng ta nó chính là ax + b. Đấy
các bạn nhìn thấy đây này. Đấy được
chưa? Thế sau khi mà các bạn đi qua cái
output này ấ thì lúc ban đầu y nó là một
cái số nằm trong khoảng từ âm vô cùng
cho đến dương vô cùng. Nhưng mà các bạn
cho qua đây rồi thì nó sẽ là một cái số
nằm khoảng từ 0 cho đến 1. Được chưa?
Đấy được chưa? Th ra cho khoảng từ 0 đến
1 này. Được chưa? Cái trục hoành nhắc
lại nhá. Trục hoành này nó chính là cái
output của mô hình linear reaction đấy.
Được chưa? Trục tung này chính là cái
output của bài toán classification. Được
chưa? Thế bây giờ bất kể cái cái giá trị
output của mô hình linear reaction ấy nó
ra giá trị nằm trong khoảng từ âm vô
cùng đến dương vô cùng. Nhưng các bạn cứ
đi qua cảm xích m này thì output nó sẽ
luôn nằm trong khoảng từ 0 cho đến 1.
Được chưa? Thế thì sau khi ra cái khoảng
1 này các bạn tưởng tượng thì đây chính
là cái số điểm mà mô hình nó gán cho cái
sample này đúng không? Chính là số điểm
mô hình nó gán cho cái người này. Thì
bây giờ so có cái điểm này người ta sẽ
soánh nó với với một cái ngưỡng. Ngưỡng
ví dụ mặc định là ngưỡng là 0,5. Được
chưa? Mặc định ngưỡng là 0,5 đúng không?
Thì bây giờ nếu mà cái giá trị đầu ra
của cái hàm xmo này nó lớn hơn 0,5 thì
tôi sẽ dự đưa dự đoán là gì? Là người
này là senior. Nếu mà nó nhỏ hơn 0,5 thì
tôi đây ví dụ đây ông này mà lớn hơn này
đúng không?
Đúng không? Nếu mà như này đúng không
các bạn? Thấy không? Nếu mà như này đúng
không? Nếu mà cái ông này nó ở đây đúng
không? Thì tôi sẽ dóng vào đây xem đây
nó 0,9 trên 0,5 rồi đúng không? Thì ông
này là senior. Còn ông còn ông ông nào
mà ở dưới này ông nào mà cho qua Sigmo
này mà dưới 0,5 thì nó là nó là chun
đúng không? Tại sao không truyền thẳng X
vào Sigmo? Không truyền thẳng được
X không truyền thẳng vào Xmo được. Vì
sao thế? Thì chúng ta đâu X mà chuyển
hỏng th là các bạn sẽ không có hệ số
luôn. Không không có cái gì để học cả.
Hàm Smo là một hàm phi tham số. Nó không
có tham số.
Hàm này nó không có tham số.
Cái mà chúng ta cái mà mô hình cần phải
học là gì? Nó phải học ra cái giá trị
của W1, W2, W3 này. Đúng không? Hay
trong trường hợp này nó học cái gì? Nó
phải học là nó phải học là A với cả B
đúng không? Nó phải học A B để nó tìm ra
đây đúng không? Nếu bây gi có X mà các
bạn cho thẳng vào sig thì làm gì có tham
số thì mô hình chả có gì để học cả đúng
không? Mô hình không có gì để học cả
đúng không? X là input đầu vào không
thay đổi được đúng không? Sigmo là hàm
cố định cũng không thay đổi được. Bây
giờ không cho nó đi qua cái tuyến tính
chứ, không có cho nó qua linear
direction trước thì hoàn toàn chẳng có
cái gì để học cả. Được chưa? Thế thì tóm
lại là gì? Tóm lại là logistic reaction
thì bằng linear reaction cộng với cái
hàm sigmid. Được chưa?
Giá trị ngưỡng mặc định là 0,5. Giống
như mình hôm nọ mình nói các bạn đấy, ví
dụ thi đại học tổng 30 điểm, 3 điểm là
maximum thôi. Thì ngưỡng chính là cái
điểm sàn đấy đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn
cho ngưỡng sàn là 10 15 điểm thì ông nào
trên 10 năm là đỗ đại học, dưới 15 là
trượt đại học thì chính là cái ngưỡng
này đấy đúng không? [khịt mũi] Thế giả
sử bây giờ các bạn muốn muốn tăng cái
recol cho class trên cho class số 1 thì
các bạn phải giảm ngưỡng đi đúng không?
Các bạn muốn tăng các bạn tăng ngưỡng
lên. Được chưa? Đây chính là toán
logistic regression.
Hai toán này rất là dễ bị nhầm với nhau
với những người mới học. Linear reaction
và logistic reaction. Tên nó hơi na ná
nhau, đều có chữ đều là bắt đầu chữ L và
kết thúc là reaction đúng không? Nên là
nó rất dễ bị nhầm với nhau. Cái sự khác
biệt là gì? Và có một điểm rất là đặc
biệt này. Cái thuật toán này ấ tên của
nó có chữ regression nhưng nó lại không
phải thuật toán dành cho bài toán
regression. Nó là thuật toán dành cho
bài toán classification đúng không? Tên
thì có chữ regression nhưng nó lại là
một th toán dành cho bài toán
classification. Được chưa?
Khi các bạn đi phỏng vấn sinh việc ấy có
câu hỏi người ta rất hay hỏi là gì? Là
phân biệt giữa linear với cả logistic
question chưa? Câu phải rất là kinh
điển, mọi người mới học rất dễ bị nhầm
với nhau nhá.
Rồi thôi như vậy thôi.
Có b nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có nào có thắc mắc gì không?
Nào có ai có thác có có thắc mắc gì với
linear hay là polynomial hay là logistic
re không? Mặc dù đều có chữ reaction
nhưng mà chỉ có hai ông đầu tiên là
reaction thôi. Ông này là trong
classification.
Được chưa? Muốn thay muốn tăng recol hay
là presume cho từng class bạn thay đổi
ngưỡng thôi. Ngưỡng tăng lên giảm xuống
là xong đúng không?
Class này mà tăng recol có nghĩa là
class kia tăng precision.
Tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Tiếp với các bạn
này. Thế nhưng mà đây là trường hợp các
bạn có hai class. Được chưa? Đây là
trường hợp có hai class đúng không? Hai
class là các bạn chỉ có 0 với 1 thôi.
Thì chúng ta dùng như này được. Thế bây
giờ nếu mà trường hợp có nhiều hơn hai
class thì các bạn làm nào? Các bạn có 3
b
ví dụ feature là điểm thi đại học ngưỡng
từ 0 đến 30 dùng mình mình không hiểu
câu hỏi thật sự thự không hiểu câu hỏi.
Ví dụ feature là điểm thi đại học ngưỡng
từ 0 đến 30 chúng ta dùng hàm gì?
Logistic regression.
Tôi nói xong đúng không? Dưới ngưỡng thì
là thì là trượt đại học mà trên ngưỡng
thì là đỗ đại học. Vừa ví dụ xong. Được
chưa?
Cả tiếp nhá. Đúng không? Thì bây giờ thế
bây giờ ờ thế bây giờ trong trường hợp
mà chúng ta có nhiều hơn hai class làm
nào? Cái hàm xmo này nó chỉ nó chỉ áp
dụng được khi mà các bạn các bạn có hai
class thôi. Nhiều hơn hai các bạn có 3 4
năm các bạn không dùng xo được. Thì
trong trường hợp mà các bạn có nhiều hơn
high class ấy, người ta phải biến đổi
một chút, nó làm khác đi một chút. Các
bạn nhìn nhá, các bạn nhìn này.
Đây này, trường hợp bên trái là trường
hợp tiêu chuẩn là khi mà các bạn chỉ có
hai cái thôi. Đấy người ta gọi là
logistic reaction đúng không? Cái
workflow như các bạn nhìn thấy đây đúng
không? X đi vào qua mô hình linear
reaction được bằng ax + b cho qua sig
được cái y đầu ra đúng không? So sánh
xem là ví dụ ngưỡng mà 0,5 đi. Trên
ngưỡng thì là class số 1, dưới ngưỡng là
class số 0. Được chưa? Thế các trường
hợp mà các bạn có nhiều hơn hai class,
ví dụ các bạn có bốn class thì các bạn
làm thế nào? Thì bây giờ ấy nếu các bạn
có bốn class thì các bạn sẽ phải có bốn
cái mô hình chạy song song với nhau.
Được chưa? Các bạn hiểu rồi. Các bạn có
bốn cái mô hình linear reaction chạy
song song với nhau được không? Người ta
gọi đây là multinominal logistic
reaction. Được chưa? Ví dụ các bạn có
input là x này. Các bạn có bốn class thì
các bạn sẽ phải có bốn cái phương trình
đúng không? 1 là ax a1x + b1 rồi a2x +
b2 a3x + b3 a4x + b4 được chưa? Các bạn
ra được bốn cái output như này được
chưa? Sau đó các bạn phải cho nó đi qua
một cái hàm hàm này gọi là hàm soft max
hàm soft max là phiên bản nâng cao so
với sig khi mà các bạn có nhiều hơn hai
class. Sắ công thức như nào các bạn nhìn
này nhá. Sắ nó như này này ví dụ nhá.
Ví dụ sau khi đi qua cái bước đầu tiên
đi qua a1x + b1 a2 + 2 các bạn có bốn
cái giá trị là ví dụ output đầu ra đó là
1,4 - 2,3
0,2 1,6 ví dụ như vậy đi được đi qua đi
qua cái đúng không đi x mà đi qua bốn
cái mô hình linear này các bạn được bốn
cái output này được chưa bây gi qua hàm
so max nhá công thức hàm s max như này
max là ví dụ cái chỗ này mình gọi nó là
t đi đúng không thì nó bằng gì nó bằng e
mũ t chia cho tổng sigma của các cái
e mũ t. Được chưa? e mũ y. y chạy từ 0
cho đến n nó bằng gì? Ví dụ -1,4 nó bằng
gì? Nó bằng e mũ 1,4 này chia cho tổng
của e mũ 1,4 cộng với e mũ -2,3 cộng với
e mũ 0,2 cộng với e mũ 1,6. Cái ông thứ
hai sẽ là bằng e mũ tr-2,3 chia cho mẫu
giống kia. Tức là gì? Bốn ông này mẫu
giống y hệt nhau, nó chỉ khác nhau mỗi
cái tử thôi. Được chưa? mọi cái tử thôi.
Thế thì
vì sao người ta lại phải đi qua cái hàm
shop này? Thì vì sau khi mà các bạn cho
cái giá trị đi qua hàm shop ấy, các bạn
sẽ được bốn con số. Bốn con số này trong
đặc điểm gì? Là chúng nó đều là các cái
số nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 1 và tổng
thì bằng 1. Ví dụ là các bạn sẽ ra được
là ví dụ như là 0,76
ờ 0,01
0,02
rồi à 0,76 này hơi to quá. Ví dụ đây
0,0,2 mấy thì 0,26 đi. Còn đây này là 0
phẩ 26 2 0,29 0,71 đi. Được chưa? Tức là
gì? Ra cái output mà tất cả các cái giá
trị nó đều nằm trong khoảng từ
đây nhá 0,26 đúng không? Tất cả các cái
giá trị này nó đều khoảng từ 0 đến 1 và
tổng đúng đúng bằng 1 luôn đúng không?
Tất cả giá trị đó khoảng từ 0 đến 1 và
tổng thì đúng bằng 1 luôn. Thì nó sẽ
giống với xác suất đúng không? Nó lại
giống như xác suất. Thế thế thì sau khi
mà cho qua ngàm S max này rồi các bạn sẽ
được giá trị là I1, I2, I3, I4 thì các
bạn sẽ tính xem cái nào max
ông nào max thì là chọn ông đấy thôi.
Thì đây cách để người ta có thể dùng
logistic version
dành cho bài toán
phân loại mà chúng ta có nhiều hơn hai
class. Được chưa? Có nhiều hơn hai
class.
Khác mỗi vậy thôi. Được chưa? Sig thì
chỉ áp dụng cho trường hợp các bạn có
hai class còn nhiều hơn 2 3 4 5 6 7
người ta sẽ dùng. SH max được chưa? Các
bạn có bao nhiêu C cũng được cứ qua S
max thì các cái giá trị output I1, I2,
I3 I4 tất cả chúng sẽ đều nằm trong
khoảng từ 0 đến 1 và tổng chủ đúng bằng
1 luôn. Nên là chúng ta sẽ luôn có thể
giải thích được số dướ dạng là xác suất.
Tức là mô hình nó dự đoán là nó là class
I1 là bao nhiêu phần trăm, I2 là bao
nhiêu phần à xin lỗi, class số 1 là bao
nhiêu phần trăm, số 2 là bao nhiêu phần
trăm, số 3 là bao nhiêu phần trăm, số 4
là bao nhiêu phần trăm. Như
thế thôi. Có bao câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Việt cho em hỏi tôi.
>> Ừ em hỏi đi.
>> Ờ với cái cái croc tức là mình đang c
mình sẽ phải tính toán theo nhiều thứ
với mỗi thread th mình tính toán lại cái
AB hay là mình chỉ đơn giản là dùng cái
thong
rồi mình em chưa biết cách
tính theo nhiều
tí RC đây á.
>> Vâng. Ừ
>> thì anh bảo là mỗi cái này thì mình sẽ
mỗi cái thả phải tính lại cái true
positive với lại positive grade đúng
>> đúng rồi.
>> Thì mỗi th đấy mình có thể xây dựng lại
mô hình tỉnh toán lại tham số không?
>> Không không phải dựng mô hình.
Ví dụ nhá ví dụ ờ ví dụ nó có hai class
đi là đỗ đại học với trượt đại học đúng
không? Class positive là class đỗ đại
học. Class negative là class trượt đại
học. Được chưa? Bây giờ ví dụ chúng ta
có 1000 sinh viên, m bạn đi thi đúng
không? Điểm các đấy là cố định rồi. Thì
bây giờ em chỉ thay đổi ngưỡng của họ
thôi. Em thay đổi ngưỡng là sẽ có ông từ
đỗ thành trượt và từ trượt thành đỗ. Lần
đầu tức những cái này nó sẽ thay đổi
theo đúng không? Tính toán lại mình mình
đâu cần phải bắt họ đi thi lại đâu. Đúng
không? Vẫn 1000 người đấy. Vẫn cái điểm
đấy. Tôi thay đổi ngưỡng thôi là tôi sẽ
có số người trượt và số k đối nó sẽ thay
đổi khác nhau. Thì mỗi khi em thay đổi
ngưỡng xong em sẽ có cái true vate nó sẽ
khác và full vate nó sẽ khác đúng không?
đâu cần phải huấn luyện lại cái gì đâu.
>> À nó chỉ là thay đổi nhãn.
>> Ừ thay đổi ngưỡng. Nó chỉ thay đổi
ngưỡng thôi. Và thay đổi ngưỡng xong là
tự nhiên sẽ có ông là đang từ class này
thành class kia hoặc là ngược lại.
>> Đấy thế thôi. Kiểu như vậy
rồi.
Có b nào câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Có cái gì chưa clear không các bạn ơi?
Tiếp nhá. Hôm nay có hỏi tiếp nhá các
bạn. Như này. Tiếp theo chúng ta sẽ đến
một cái thuật toán tiếp theo. Cái thuật
toán này ấ nó dựa trên một cái kiến thức
xác suất rất là cơ bản mà các bạn nào
các bạn học à hình như cấp ba thì chưa
có cái này nhưng mà lên đại học thì nó
có rồi.
Ờ lớp mình có bạn nào các bạn từng được
học về sáu thầm kê các bạn quyết khái
niệm về xất suất có điều kiện không? Có
bạn nào các bạn biết sá suất có điều
kiện nó cái gì cho mình số một. Có bạn
chưa nghe khái niệm này có bao giờ cho
mình số 0 được không? Số thất có điều
kiện
rồi bạn nào các bạn học th các bạn học
cao đẳng cái đà học các bạn đều biết
khái niệm này đúng không các bạn sẽ có
môn môn sắp suất tống kê được không rồi
các bạn sẽ học về số có điều kiện sắp
suất có điều kiện có nghĩa là gì tức là
xác suất để xảy ra sự kiện này biết rằng
một sự kiện kia xảy ra được chưa mình
lấy ví dụ cho các bạn nhá ví dụ cho các
bạn là bây giờ mình có hai cái sự kiện
đi. Mình có mình mình có hai cái sự kiện
là ví dụ này đi. Ví dụ nhá, sự kiện a,
sự kiện a là sự kiện các bạn đỗ đại học.
Đại học được chưa? Sự kiện B là sự kiện
các bạn học trăm
được chưa? Học trăm thì bình thường ấy
hồi ngày xưa ấy, hồi ngày xưa mà chúng
ta học hồi học cấp ba ấy đúng không? Cấp
hai cấp 3 học về xác suất ấ các bạn chỉ
học đơn giản như là PA.
PA là xác suất chúng ta đỗ đại học.
Nhưng mà thật ra ấy thông thường trong
trong thực tế cái xác suất này
rất là khó để có thể tính trực tiếp. Tại
vì sao? Tại vì cái việc mà chúng ta đỗ
đại học ấy nó sẽ phụ thuộc vào nhiều yếu
tố rất là khó để tính trực tiếp nó ngay.
Thế lên đại học các bạn sẽ có một cái
khái niệm là sáu rất có điều kiện. Người
ta ký hiệu này P của A sọc cái B này tức
là gì? Xác suất để các bạn đỗ đại học
biết rằng các bạn học trăng. Được chưa?
Xác suất để các bạn đỗ đại học và biết
rằng các bạn học trăm. Tức là gì? Đã có
một cái điều kiện gì đấy trước xảy ra
rồi, thỏa mãn rồi. Tôi tính xác suất là
để một cái sự kiện sau đấy nó xảy ra.
Được chưa? Xác suất để A xảy ra. Biết
rằng B xảy ra rồi. Được chưa? Thế thì
từ công thức này đây. Công thức cậy này
các bạn này nhá. Xác suất để xảy ra A
biết rằng B xảy ra rồi thì bằng cái gì?
Dựa vào cái best theorem này, định lý BS
này nó sẽ bằng gì? Nó bằng xác suất xảy
ra B. Biết rằng A xảy ra rồi nhân xác
suất xảy ra A. Rồi chia cho số thể là B.
Ví dụ trong trường hợp vừa rồi đúng
không? A là đỗ đại học đúng không? B là
học trăm đúng không? Không đỗ đại học
trăm thì ví dụ này nó thì nó sẽ hơi sẽ
hơi nó sẽ khó để mình lấy một cái ví dụ
khác đi. Lấy một cái ví dụ khác đi.
Lấy ví dụ khác mà nó không có cái thứ tự
về mặt thời gian đi thì nó sẽ nó sẽ hơn.
Ví dụ như là
gì nhỉ?
À
sao tự em mình không nghĩ ra ví dụ nhỉ?
Làm anh
anh dùng test Covid với cả bị bệnh cũng
được
>> à. Ừ cũng được. Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Test
Covid ở dố dán thế này đúng không? Tức
là tức là A là cái sự kiện mà các bạn
được không phải các bạn được các bạn bị
dương tính đúng không? A là các bạn bị
dương à các bạn bị dương tính. Còn B là
sự kiện mà các bạn bị bệnh thật đúng
không? B là các bạn bị bệnh thật còn A
là các bạn test ra mà bị dương tính đúng
không? Thì xác suất để các bạn test
Covid ấy mà bị mà bị dương tính biết
rằng các bạn bị bệnh thật ấy nó bằng cái
gì? Bằng xác suất để các bạn bị bệnh
thật sau khi người ta test các bạn là
các bạn bị dương tính rồi đúng không?
Nhân với sát suất mà các bạn
dương tính chia cho sá suất các bạn bị
bệnh được chưa? Được chưa? Đúng không?
Đấy đây là sá suất gọi là s công thức
công thức BS đấy đúng không? Nó dựa vào
sá suất có điều kiện nhớ thì rất là dễ
thôi. Ngày xưa như mẹ nhớ là gì? Thì cái
ông đứng sau phải ông này nó giống nhau
đúng b này aa đúng không? Hay ông nào đi
cùng tại vì nhân chéo lên nó cùng với mà
đúng không? Cái ông đứng đằng sau với
ông này phải giống nhau. Ông đứng sau
ông này giống nhau. Mình nhớ ngày xưa là
như thế đấy. Cái kiểu này best theorem
đây. Đị ý rất là nổi tiếng trong xác
suất đúng không? Phổ thông là chỉ học
xác suất đơn lẻ thôi. Đơn đại học sẽ học
về xác suất có điều kiện. Được chưa? Thế
bây giờ công thức này các bạn nhìn nhá.
Thế bây giờ
giả sử đi giả sử như này đi. Bây giờ giả
sử mình muốn huấn luyện một cái mô hình
dành cho mảng np. Mình muốn huấn luyện
cái mô hình này để làm sao để cái mô
hình nó có khả năng nó có thể phân loại
được xem là những cái
những cái đoạn tex này mỗi một đoạn tex
là một cái sample nhá. Mỗi một đoạn tex
là một sample thì mình muốn làm sao mình
có thể huấn lể làm sao nó dựa vào cái đ
nội dung đạn tex nó sẽể nó dự đoán xem
là đạo tex này nó có ý nghĩa là positive
hay là negative được chưa positive hay
là negative. Positive là khen negative
là chê kiểu kiểu như vậy. Được chưa? Thế
mình muốn sử dụng cái mô hình như vậy để
làm sao sau để trong tương lai mình có
những cái đoạn tex mới vào mô hình nó sẽ
phân loại được xem là đoạn tex này là
theo ý nghĩa là positive hay negative
đúng không? Đấy là cái ý tưởng của mình.
Mình muốn làm như vậy. Thế bây giờ mình
sẽ làm cái theo mình xem cái mình xem
cái tiếp cận này tức là gì? Bây giờ ấy
mình theo cái tiếp cận là gì? Là tôi
muốn biết xem là một cái đoạn tex ấy nó
positive hay là nó negative ý tôi chỉ
cần tôi
tôi chỉ cần tôi tôi dựa vào các cái từ
của nó. Tôi dựa vào các cái từ nó xuất
hiện. Được chưa? Thế tôi một cái việc
này là gì? Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ đúng không
các cái từ như là you are pity hay là
annoying chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì nó
đều là các cái từ đúng không? Thì bây
giờ mình muốn là gì? Mình muốn là bây
giờ tôi sẽ đưa nó về bài toán xác suất.
Tức là gì? Tôi muốn xem là bây giờ nếu
một cái đoạn texch ấy nó có chứa cái từ
này, từ này, từ này thì xác suất nó là
positive là bao nhiêu, xác nó là
negative là bao nhiêu, đúng không? Thì
ví dụ trong trường hợp này nhá, đúng
không? Thì bây giờ ví dụ mình có một cái
câu như này đi, mình có mình mình lấy
một cái câu cụ thể đây là you are pretty
annoying đúng không? Bây giờ mình muốn
là cái mô hình mình nó sẽ dừa xem là cái
câu này nó là
ý nghĩa positive hay negative thì mình
làm thế nào thì bây giờ sẽ xác tính cái
xác suất là gì? Xác suất mà nó có nghĩa
positive biết rằng nó có bốn cái từ này
và mình cũng sẽ tính xác suất nó là
negative biết rằng nó có bốn cái từ này.
Được chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ làm gì? Các
bạn nhìn nhá. Theo công thức 3s đây đúng
không? Công thức 3s nó nó như này đúng
không? Tôi sẽ phải tính được gì? Xác
suất đây đúng không? Xác suất để cái
đoạn tách này nó là positive. Biết rằng
nó có chứa các cái từ là you are pretty
annoying đúng không? Thì bằng cái gì?
Bằng xác suất để nó có chứa các cái từ
này biết rằng nó có ý nghĩa tích cực này
đúng không? Đây đúng không? B the này
các bạn nhìn thấy nó như này đây. Như
này như này như này đúng không các bạn?
Nhìn nó như này
được chưa? Đây này. Rồi có ths là như
này được chưa? Các bạn có thể tính được
gì? Đầu tiên nhá riêng các bạn nhìn này.
Đây là mình chỉ lấy riêng cái phần cái
phần mình khoanh vuông này thôi nhá.
Mình chỉ lấy riêng cái phần này thôi
nhá. Được chưa? Riêng cái phần này được
chưa? Tức là gì? Tôi muốn tôi chỉ tính
riêng cái xác suất đúng không? Riêng một
phần của cái tử số thôi đúng không? Còn
cái phần p positive về PW này tôi chưa
tính đến được chưa? Chỉ riêng phần này
thôi. Bệnh này xác suất để gì? Xác suất
để cái đoạn tex của tôi có chứa từ, từ
a, từ pry, từ từ annoying. Biết rằng nó
là một đoạn một là một đoạn tex
positive. Nó bằng cái gì? Tôi lại tách
tiếp ra đúng không? Tách tách lẻ thế này
bằng xác suất để có từ biết rằng nó
positive này nhân với xác suất có cái từ
a biết rằng nó có từ và positive này rồi
tiếp tục u này nó rất là dài như thế này
đúng không cái công thức này mà các bạn
ngồi các bạn tính thì nó rất là dài đúng
không nó rất là dài rất là khó đúng
không sất rất có điều kiện lại tách nhỏ
ra thành nhiều cái sất su rất có điều
kiện con đúng không dựa lúc ps nó rất là
lằng nhằn được chưa thế thì bây giờ ấy
người ta sẽ đơn giản hóa nó
người ta đơn giản hóa nó bằng bằng cách
Nào người ta đơn giản nó bằng bằng là
việc là người ta sẽ thêm vào một cái giả
thuyết. Người ta sẽ thêm vào một cái giả
thuyết. Giả thuyết người ta thêm vào là
cái gì? Người ta sẽ thêm giải thích là
gì? Là người ta sẽ giả định rằng là nếu
tôi đã biết là cái đoạn tách này nó có ý
nghĩa là positive hay là cái negative
rồi thì các cái từ của tôi, các cái đặc
trưng đấy chính là các cái từ ấy nó sẽ
hoàn toàn độc lập vào nhau. Được chưa?
Chúng nó sẽ hoàn toàn độc lập vào nhau.
Tức là gì? Tức là nếu tôi đã biết là cái
đoạn tex này của tôi nó có cái đoạn tex
là you are pry này. Nếu tôi đã biết là
nó là positive rồi hoặc tôi biết nó là
negative rồi thì xác suất hay là khả
năng mà các cái từ you are pry aning này
xuất hiện ấy nó độc lập độc lập với
nhau. Ông này không ảnh hưởng không có
dây mơ dễ ma gì đến ông kia cả. Được
chưa? Thì đấy là cái giả thiết mà tôi
thêm vào. Tôi thêm vào để tôi tính cái
này nó cho nó dễ hơn nhá. Tôi thêm vào
cái điều kiện như này được chưa? Nếu tôi
đã biết là nó thuộc về cái lớp nào rồi,
lớp positive hay lớp negative rồi đúng
không? Đấy, lớp đây là chính là positive
negative này, đúng không? Mỗi một từ
chính là một cái đặc trưng thì nhờ đúng
không? Tức là gì? Tức là nếu tôi biết là
cái đoạn tách đấy nó thuộc về class gì
rồi thì việc cái đoạn tách này nó có
chứa từ pretty hay không ấy nó sẽ hoàn
toàn không ảnh hưởng đến bất kỳ một cái
từ nào khác. Tức là gì? Những cái từ này
nó sẽ không được liên quan đến nhau. Nó
sẽ không liên quan đến nhau. Ông này có
hay không không ảnh hưởng gì đến ông
kia. Thế thì khi mà tôi đã thêm một cái
tôi đã thêm cái giải trước này rồi ấ thì
công thức tôi nó sẽ dễ hơn. Nhìn này,
lúc mà chúng ta công thức gốc ban đầu nó
nó như thế này đúng không? Riêng cái
phần các bạn nhìn thấy không? Riêng cái
phần ờ xác suất để có từ a từ pt từ biết
rằng nó positive này đúng không? Bình
thường là nó công thức ở trên được chưa?
Nhưng mà bây giờ sau khi mà tôi đã biết
là nó thu về class positive rồi thì xác
suất để nó có từ du a ping ấy nó là độc
lập với nhau. Thì bây giờ tôi sẽ có thể
tôi tách ra sẽ đơn giản hóa gì cái phần
màu cạm màu hồng này đúng không? Tại vì
bây giờ từ A với từ nó độc lập với nhau
đúng không? Vì nó độc lập nên là có xuất
hiện hay không nó chả ảnh hưởng gì đến A
cả thì tôi sẽ viết ngắn gọn nó nhanh như
này được chưa? Vì là pretty a với cả nó
độc lập với nhau nên là hay a nó có xảy
ra hay không nó cũng chả ảnh hưởng gì
đến pr cả như này như này đúng không? Và
khi làm này nó sẽ đơn giản hơn rất là
nhiều. Đúng không? Nhờ tôi chèn thêm một
cái điều kiện là gì? Là là cái khả năng
các cái feature nó xảy ra ấy nó sẽ độc
lập với nhau khi mà tôi đã biết là nó
trúng thuộc về class nào rồi đúng không?
Thì đây chính là cái ý tưởng của một cái
thuật toán trong machine. Nó gọi là
knife knife này tiếng Việt mình nghĩa gì
các bạn? Từ knife này nghĩa nghĩa là gì?
Cái từ knife này nghĩa là gì?
>> Ngây thơ.
>> Ngây thơ. Đúng rồi. Ngây thơ. Vì sao
người ta lại gọi là ngây thơ? Tại vì là
cái thứ mà chúng ta dựa vào ấy nó là thứ
nó nó ngây thơ đúng không? Cái thứ mà
chúng ta vừa mới giả giả đệ ấ nó là cái
thứ mà thông thường trong tự tế nó sẽ
không tồn tại. Tại vì sao? Thông thường
ấy thì việc mà các từ này nó xuất hiện
nhau ấy nó phải có một cái mối quan hệ
gì đấy đúng không? Giống kiểu trong mình
ngôn ngữ của con người mà đúng không?
Phải có chủ ngữ rồi đến vị ngữ, phải có
động từ rồi đến trạng từ. Tức là các cái
từ nó phải có một cái mối quan hệ gì đấy
chứ không thể nào có chuyện là các cái
từ nó hoàn toàn nó đập lập với nhau. Nên
là thật ra ấy cái giả thuyết mà nếu
chúng ta đã biết là đoạn tex này nó thu
về class positive hoặc negative ý thì
việc cái đoạn tex này có chứa các cái từ
pretty, từ annoying, từ beautiful hay gì
ấy chúng nó độc lập với nhau. Đây thết
nó rất là nó rất là phi thực tế. Nó rất
là phi thực tế đúng không? Trong thực tế
nó sẽ không có cái chuyện như vậy đúng
không? Làm gì có chuyện mà một cái văn
bản mà các cái từ xuất hiện lại khả năng
lại độp lập với nhau đúng không? Nhưng
người ta cho nó thêm vào để làm gì? Để
tính cho nó dễ đúng không? Để tính cho
nó dễ. Tại vì nếu mà chúng ta không cho
cái điều kiện này vào ấy đúng không?
Chúng ta không có thêm cái điều kiện độc
lập như vậy ấ thì tính những cái chỗ này
nó rất là khó. Nó rất là khó. Thế nhưng
mà vì bây giờ chúng ta cho thêm điều
kiện rồi nó rất là dễ đúng không? Bây
giờ tôi sẽ xác suất để cái đoạn tex nó
có từ biết rằng nó positive rồi nhân với
suất có từ a biết positive cái này nó
rất là dễ. Nó rất là dễ. Được chưa? Thế
đây chính là cái tậ toán được gọi là ns.
Tộ toán này nó dựa trên cái giải thuyết
là gì? là các cái feature của tôi sẽ
hoàn toàn độc lập với nhau nếu tôi đã
biết chúng tôi về cái class gì rồi. Và
vì như vậy tính này nó rất là dễ này các
bạn nhìn này. Này tại vì sao
tôi muốn tính hai cái ông này đúng
không? Tôi muốn tính là tôi muốn tính là
gì? Xác suất để nó là positive biết rằng
nó có cái chứa từ này rồi và xất rằng có
negative biết chứ cái từ này rồi đúng
không? Thì bây giờ ví dụ cái positive
nhá đúng không bạn? Pitif này đúng
không? Nó đúng không? Muốn tính cái ông
này thì phải tính được cái ông này đúng
không? Mà cái ông này ấy chính là cái
thứ mà chúng ta vừa đơn giản hóa đấy
đúng không? Nếu chúng ta không đơn giản
hóa thì tính này nó cực kỳ phức tạp đúng
không? Xác suất của W biết rằng positive
rồi đây đúng không? Rất là phức tạp rất
là phức tạp. Đây rất phức tạp trên đây
nhưng mà nhờ cái sảy vừa rồi nên nó đơn
giản hơn và tương tự vậy với negative nó
cũng thế đúng không? Tức là gì? Bây giờ
các cái từ của tôi mạch ai thì đây đúng
không? Chả ông nào liên quan đến ông nào
cả đúng không? Sắp suất của ông này hoàn
toàn chả liên quan gì đến ông kia cả.
Tính nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn. Được chưa? Thế
thì đây là ý tưởng của N 3S là một thuật
toán mà rất là đơn giản nhưng mà cái
tính áp dụng của nó thì nó cũng khá là
hạn chế tại vì nó dựa trên một cái điều
kiện mà rất là khó tồn tại. Nó dựa trên
một cái điều kiện là rất khó tồn tại.
Rất khó có chuyện mà các bạn có một cái
bộ dữ liệu mà các cái feature nó lại độc
lập với nhau như vậy. Được chưa?
VS
thì thì từ cái live này người ta sẽ chia
ra nhiều cái thuật tán con mà thôi cái
này thì chúng ta đ đến đến cuối khóa nếu
mà chúng ta có thời gian thì mình sẽ
quay lại. Thế nhưng mà cái thuật này
toán trong thực tế nó rất ít khi người
ta dùng. Thế nhưng mà khi mà học về
machining người ta lại rất hay đưa về
toán này. Tại vì đều thoán nó một trong
số tự toán rất là cơ bản rất là cơ bản
nhưng mà học tế nó lại ít ít có chỗ dùng
nhá. Đến cuối khóa n có thời gian mình
sẽ quay lại về cái phần này nhá.
Ok.
Thế thôi có nào có câu hỏi gì không? Có
bạn nào có thắc mắc gì không các bạn?
Tạm vờ các bạn chỉ nhớ đến đây thôi nhá.
Còn với cái phần sau này thì mình nghĩ
là để những cái buổi sau khi chúng ta
thực hành tương đối nhiều rồi mình sẽ
quay lạiở đây mình giải thích thêm một
lượt nữa để cho các bạn xem là nó có
những cái biến thể gì nhá.
Rồi có ai có thắc mắc gì không các bạn
nhá? Kifs được chưa? Bảo toán rất là cơ
bản. Nó cơ bản ngang với linear reaction
nó cũng dựa vào hai âm này nó đều dựa
vào cái giả thuyết mà tuyến tính. Thế
nhưng mà nếu mà linear re ấy là nó tuyến
tính sẵn rồi, bản thân nó là tuyến tính
rồi thì cái nại phải đưa thêm một cái
giả thuyết vào. Phải đưa cái giả thuyết
là gì? Các cái feature là nó hoàn toàn
cho nó độc lập với nhau. Được chưa?
Tiếp các bạn nhá. Tiếp nhá. Thì bây giờ
tôi sẽ nói về một cái thao toán khác.
Thế bây giờ giả sử mình có một cái bài
toán như này. Mình có bài toán là bây
giờ mình muốn sử dụng cái mô hình để làm
sao có thể
có thể gợi ý xem một cái công ty họ có
nên nhận một cái nhân viên nào đấy hay
không. Được chưa nhá? Tức là bây giờ ví
dụ có một cái nhân viên đầu vào. Nhân
viên này mỗi một cái nhân viên đầu vào
mình sẽ có những thông tin như là anh ta
có bằng này học hay không? Nếu có thì có
bằng giỏi hay không? Ờ có kinh nghiệm
làm việc hay không? Hay là có bằng I hay
không? Đúng không? Ví dụ như vậy. Được
chưa?
Bất kỳ người nào vào tôi cũng có đúng
bốn thông tin này. Thì bây giờ ấy tôi
muốn làm sao tôi có thể xây dựng một cái
mô hình để làm sao để tôi có thể gợi ý
cho công ty là với một người đầu vào dựa
vào thông tin của họ này tôi có nên nhận
họ hay không? Thì giả sử nhá, giả sử giả
sử là gì? Giả sử là cái mô hình của tôi
đúng không? Giả sử mô hình của tôi tôi
sử dụng cái mô hình nó như này. Đây là
mô hình nó có dạng cây được không? Đây m
hình nó có dạng cây. Bạn nào có học có
mệ thông tin rồi các bạn biết được cái
cấu cấu trúc dạng cây đúng không? Một
trong số những cấu trúc cơ bản được
chưa? Dạng cây. Thế bây giốt.
Những cái nốt này là những cái nơi mà
tôi sẽ đặt ra câu hỏi. Được chưa? Ví dụ
là gì? Có bằng đại học hay không? Có
bằng giỏi hay không? Có kinh nghiệm hay
không? Có eo hay không? Đúng không? Đây
người ta gọi là decision note, là note
quyết định là nơi mà các bạn sẽ đặt ra
câu hỏi, các bạn sẽ phải trả lời câu hỏi
này. Được chưa? Thế ngoài ra tôi sẽ có
những cái nốt gọi là trong những trong
những cái decion node này tôi có một cái
nốt đặc biệt gọi là root note. Nó là nốt
tra của cả cái cây này. Nó là cái nốt
đầu tiên. Được chưa? Nó là nốt đầu tiên.
Thế ngoài ra tôi sẽ có những cái lif
note là những cái nốt nốt nốt lá. Nốt lá
là nơi mà chúng tôi sẽ phải đưa ra quyết
định là gì? Là tôi có nhận cái ứng cự
viên này hay không. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ giả sử nhá. Giả sử tôi đã xây dựng
xong cái mô hình rồi và trông nó như thế
này được không? Giả sử tôi đã xây dựng
xong rồi và nó trông như thế này. Được
chưa? Tức là gì? Tức là bây giờ nếu mà
có một người người ta vào tôi sẽ kiểm
tra xem là có bằng đại học hay không.
Được chưa? Nếu có bằng đại học tôi sẽ
kiểm tra tiếp là gì? Là bằng là bằng gì
đúng không? Tôi xem có bằng giỏi không?
Nếu bằng giỏi tôi nhận luôn. Được chưa?
Còn nếu không phải bằng giỏi tôi kiểm ra
tiế là có I không? Nếu có I tôi nhận còn
không có I tôi từ chối. Đây là một
nhánh. Tiếp theo là gì? là cái người lúc
ban đầu tôi check ấy là có bằng đại học
hay không. Nếu anh ta không có bằng tôi
sẽ kiểm tra tiếp là gì là có kinh nghiệm
hay không. Nếu có kinh nghiệm thì thì
tôi nhận còn không có thì tôi chỗ đúng
không? Thì ví dụ đây là một cái cây, cái
này người ta gọi là cây quyết định đó là
decision tree. Decision tre tức là gì?
Đây là một cái cây quyết định mà tôi sẽ
dựa vào cái điều kiện, dựa vào cái câu
hỏi để tôi có thể tôi đưa ra quyết định
xem là tôi có nhận người này hay không.
Được chưa? Thì đây là một thuật toán
cũng rất là phổ biến trong machining.
Decentry được chưa? Decentry rất là phổ
biến trong machining.
Thế nhưng mà về với cái câu hỏi là đây
là tôi có m hình xong rồi. Thế nhưng mà
nếu mà tôi có từ đầu nếu mà lúc ban đầu
mà tôi chả có cái gì cả thì làm sao để
tôi xây dựng được cái cây như này? Làm
sao để tôi để để tôi biết là lúc ban đầu
tôi phải dùng cái thông tin về bằng đại
học mà không phải dùng thông tin khác
tôi làm thế nào? Thì bây giờ trước khi
nói về đấy các bạn nhìn nhá. Cách mà
người ta cách mà người ta huấn luyện như
này nhá. Các bạn tưởng tượng này bây giờ
nhá, giả sử đúng không? Bây giờ nhá, giả
sử đúng không? Giả sử cái bộ tôi có một
cái bộ dữ liệu về 1000 người. Được chưa?
Tôi có một bộ dữ liệu về 1000 người đi
đúng không? 1000 người đã từng ứng tuyển
vào công ty này. Trong số 1000 người này
thì có những người tôi nhận và có những
người tôi không nhận. Được chưa? Thì bây
giờ các bạn nhìn nhá. Tôi sẽ đi theo
từng nhánh một. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Đầu
tiên là tôi có 1000 người. Tôi đặt ra
câu hỏi là anh ta có bằng đại học hay
không? Thì trong số 1000 người này có
600 người có bằng đại học thì đi sang
nhánh bên trái và có 400 người không có
bằng đại học thì sang nhánh bên phải.
Được chưa? Thế bây về cái nhánh bên trái
này.
Sau khi mà 600 người có bạn đại học rồi
tôi sẽ hỏi xem là anh ta có bằng giỏi
không. Được chưa? Trong một trong 600
người này có 500 người có bằng giỏi sự
là có có 100 người có bằng giỏi được
chưa? 100 người có bằng giỏi đúng không?
Và có 500 người là không có bằng giỏi.
Được chưa? Trong 100 người này, trong
100 người có bằng giỏi trong cái bộ dệu
huấn luyện này thì cả 100 người tôi đã
đều từng nhận và không có ai tôi không
nhận cả đúng không? Thì tỉ lệ nó 100
được chưa? 100 thì rõ ràng là số người
nhận nhiều hơn số người không nhận thì
sau này có một người mới vào mà anh ta
có bằng đại học và bằng giỏi thì tôi sẽ
nhận anh ta. Được chưa? Thế còn bây giờ
cái nhánh mà không có bằng giỏi đúng
không? Có bằng đại học nhưng mà không
phải bằng giỏi bằng khá hoặc bằng trung
bình thôi. Thì tôi sẽ xét hết thêm là có
ai hay không. Thì với câu hỏi có hay
không ấy thì có 200 người là có và 300
người là không có. Được chưa? Trong 200
người thì bây giờ này trong 200 người mà
từng có bằng e ấy thì có 120 người tôi
đã từng nhận rồi và có 80 người tôi
không nhận tôi từ chối. Mà 120 thì lớn
hơn 80. Có nghĩa là gì? Sau này trong
tương lai nếu có một người có bằng đại
học không phải bằng giỏi nhưng mà lại có
I thì tôi sẽ nhận. Tại vì là 120 lớn hơn
80 mà. Được chưa?
Và cái nhánh mà có bằng đại học này,
không có bằng giỏi này mà cũng không có
eo luôn đúng không? Thì có tổng cộng là
300 người. Trong 300 người trong quá khứ
thì công ty đã từng nhận 100 người và có
200 người công ty chối. Do đó 100 thì
nhỏ hơn 200 nên là sau này mà có một
người nào tương tự như vậy thì tôi sẽ từ
chối luôn. Tại vì là trong số những
người trong quá khứ là phần lớn tôi từ
chối mà đúng không? Và tương tự như vậy
cái nhánh bên này cũng thế thôi. Trong
số 400 người mà không có bằng đại học
thì tôi sẽ hỏi tiếp là có kinh nghiệm
hay không? Trong 400 người này thì có
100 người có kinh nghiệm. Trong 100
người có kinh nghiệm đã từng upline vào
công ty thì công ty nhận 80 và từ chối
20. Nên là sau này có một ông nào mới
ông đấy vào ông đấy cũng không có bằng
đại học mà có kinh nghiệm tôi sẽ nhận.
Tại vì là đa số trong các thứ là tôi
nhận mà đúng không? Còn trong số 300
người mà không có kinh nghiệm này thì
tôi đã từng nhận 50 và tôi từ chối 250
rồi đúng không? Mà 50 thì nhỏ hơn 250
nên là trong tương lai nếu có ông nào mà
không có bằng đại học cũng chả có kinh
nghiệm luôn để tôi từ chối người ta.
Được chưa? Thì đây là cách để người ta
có thể người ta
đây là cái luồng hoạt động của DC đúng
không? Hoạt động DC nó cứ đi theo cái
hướng như vậy đúng không? Bao giờ nó
theo quy tắc là gì? Là trả lời câu hỏi
và đa số đánh mạnh thiểu số đúng không
các bạn nhé? Ở mỗi một cái nốt lá này
đúng không? Nó luôn dựa theo quy tắc đa
số đánh bại thiểu số. Đa số thuộc về đâu
thì trong tương lai tôi sẽ
trong tương lai tôi sẽ dựa vào cái đa số
ấy để tôi quyết định đúng không? 120 lớn
hơn 80 trong tương lai ông nào vào đây
tôi sẽ dựa vào cái nhánh là nhận đúng
không? Còn đây là 100 nhỏ hơn 200 trong
tương lai mà hôm nay có đây tôi sẽ tư
chốt. Được chưa? Đây là cách để DC entry
nó hoạt động được chưa? Luôn dựa theo
đặt câu hỏi và đa số đánh mạnh thiểu số
chá.
Thế bây giờ thế bây giờ nhưng mà cái
nhưng mà cái câu hỏi chính vẫn vẫn chưa
được trả lời là gì? là bây giờ vì sao
cái nút gốc này tôi lại chọn là có bằng
đại học mà tôi không chọn là bằng giỏi
hay là I hay là kinh nghiệm thô tức là
vì sao tôi có bốn cái đặc trưng vì sao
cái đặc trưng đầu tiên tôi hỏi lại là
bằng đại học mà không phải những cái thứ
khác bằng đại học nó có cái gì nó hơn
những cái kia có cái tiêu chí gì để tôi
trong quá trình tôi xây dựng tôi biết là
tôi nên chọn cái ông nào cái nốt gốc này
đúng không phải có một cái tiêu chí gì
đấy chứ không thể nào mà tự nhiên trên
giờ giữa xuống lại có cái bảng này được
đúng không đây là mô hình sau khi huấn
luyện xong rồi nó như thế này đúng không
nhưng Mà khi mà tôi chưa huấn luyện thì
tôi lấy cái gì để tôi chỉ ra là gì? Là
là là là
ờ là tôi chọn cái bằng đại học những cái
khác đúng không? Ba kia nó cũng nó cũng
có tiềm năng mà đúng không? Cớ gì tôi
lại chọn bằng đại học. Thế thì bây giờ
ấy để biết tôi chọn cái nào ấy thì bây
giờ các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ để làm sao
để chúng ta biết là người ta dựa vào
tiêu chí gì thì bây giờ chúng ta hãy hãy
hãy coi như nhá hãy coi như là tôi đang
tôi sẽ sử dụng cái mô hình từ đầu được
chưa? Tôi sử dụng cái mô hình từ đầu.
Tôi có một cái bộ dữ liệu có liên quan
đến các cái dự đến cái vay vốn ngân
hàng. Được chưa? Tôi có một cái bộ dữ
liệu có liên quan đến vay vốn ngân hàng.
Cái bộ diện này tôi chính tôi có ít
thôi. Tôi chỉ có 14 người thôi. Đây là
14 người đã từng đến ngân hàng của tôi
vay tiền. Mỗi người tôi có thông tin là
gì? Về tuổi của họ, về thu nhập của họ,
về cái trạng thái là họ có phải sinh
viên hay không và cái chỉ số tín dụng
của họ đúng không? Và
có người tôi cho vay, có người tôi không
cho vay. Thì bây giờ tôi muốn dựa vào
cái bộ dựa này, tôi xây dựng một cái mô
hình, một cái decision tre, một cây
quyết định để làm sao trong tương lai có
người đến họ muốn vay tiền thì tôi sẽ
quyết định xem là tôi có cho họ vay hay
không. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ tôi có bốn
cái feature là, income, e student với cả
credit rating. Tôi sẽ phải quyết định
xem là tôi lấy ông nào là gốc bây giờ.
Tôi lấy ông nào là gốc bây giờ? Thì các
bạn nhìn nhá.
Thì bây giờ như này đây đúng không? Tôi
sẽ có bốn cái khả năng đúng không? Tôi
có bốn khả năng đúng không? Tôi chọn là
gốc thì tôi sẽ có cái cây như này nó có
ba nhánh. Tôi chọn income là gốc tôi sẽ
có một cây cũng có ba nhánh đúng không?
Tôi chọn student là gốc tôi có một cây
có hai nhánh. Và tôi có cái credit
rating này, tôi sẽ có cây cũng có hai
nhánh như này. Được chưa? Tôi phải xem
là trong bốn ông này ông nào trường hợp
nào là trường hợp tốt nhất.
Thế thì bây giờ ấy tôi muốn biết xem là
trường hợp nào là trường hợp tốt nhất
thì tôi phải xem cái để ý xem là nếu tôi
chọn trúng thì kết quả chơ như thế nào.
Các bạn nhìn này,
các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá. Các bạn cho
mình hỏi này ờ
ở đây nhá, trong hai cái trường hợp này,
trong hai cái trường hợp này, trong hai
cái trường hợp thứ nhất ấy là người mà
người mà có bằng đại học này
không có bằng giỏi nhưng mà có I là nó ở
cái chỗ này này, cái chỗ góp dư cù bên
trái này đúng không? Đây là một trường
hợp này. Cái trường hợp thứ hai là
trường hợp mà không có bằng đại học này
cũng chả có kinh nghiệm luôn. vào cái
chỗ này này các bạn cho mình hỏi này khi
mà bây giờ trong tương lai ấy có một
người mới đến ấy thì theo các bạn là nếu
cái người mới này nó rơi vào cái trường
hợp này và rơi vào cái trường hợp này
đâu cái trường hợp mà nhận ở đây với cả
từ chối ở đây theo các bạn trong hai
trường hợp này ấy trường hợp nào thì khi
mà chúng ta đưa ra quyết định chúng ta
sẽ chắc chắn vào về quyết định của chúng
ta hơn cái trường hợp dưới này và trường
hợp trên này trường hợp nào khi mà chúng
ta đưa ra quyết định chúng ta sẽ chắc
chắn về cái dự đoán của chắc chắn cái
quyết định chúng của chúng ta hơn.
Trường hợp nào các bạn?
Trường hợp nhận ở dưới này hay trường
hợp từ chối này? Trường hợp nào chúng ta
sẽ chắc chắn hơn?
Chỗ này chắc chắn hơn đúng không? Từ
chối này. Vì sao? Vì sao cái từ chối các
bạn lại chắc chắn hơn cái nhận này? Vì
sao?
Vì sao?
Vì sao cái từ chối này các bạn lại chắc
chắn hơn là hơn là hơn là cái nhận này?
Vì sao?
Vì
à đúng rồi vì nó chênh lệch nhiều. Đúng
rồi. Chính xác chính xác. Thế thì khi mà
người ta xây dựng decision tre người ta
sẽ ưu tiên là cái feature nào nó làm cho
các bạn nó lệch nhá. Lệch là cái quan
trọng nhất nó. Người ta sẽ chọn người ta
sẽ chọn cái feature nào mà làm cho dự
bạn nó lệch. Nó càng lệch thì càng tốt
đúng không? Càng lệch thì càng tốt. Ví
dụ nhá. Ví dụ các bạn nhìn này, cái dec
thích những cái ông như này. Các bạn
nhìn này, cái ông này này. Đây các bạn
nhìn chuột mình đúng không? Nó sẽ rất
thích những cái ông như này. Đúng không?
Cái ông mà ờ 40 như này. Cái ông mình
không biết là mình record này mình có
record chuột không nhỉ? Mình không biết
là các bạn xem qua record có nhìn thấy
con chuột của mình không? Các bạn chờ
mình tí nhá. Mình xem mình xem record
chuột được không.
À
>> vẫn nhìn mình rời nhá.
>> Không. Các bạn nhìn thì được nhưng mà
mình không biết là lúc lúc record thì
không biết là nó có nhìn thấy chưa không
sao. Thì hôm nay thử cái nhá. Tức là gì?
Tức là khi mà cái m nó rất ít nhá nhánh
là H cái midle này thì sao nó rất là
lệch. 40 lệch rất tốt hoặc là 61 lệch
cũng tốt hoặc là hoặc là 26 lệch rất là
tốt đúng không? Nhanh nó càng lệch thì
khi mà các bạn đưa ra cái dự đoán ấy nó
càng nó càng đáng tin cậy. Chứ còn những
cái thứ như kiểu là 23 với cả 32 ấy thì
nó sẽ không muốn. Tại vì 232 thì hoặc là
hoặc là hoặc là hoặc là hoặc là 33 hoặc
là 34 này nó sẽ không muốn như thế này.
Được không? 33 34 32 này nó sẽ không
muốn. Tại vì sao? Tại vì khi như vậy thì
cái dự đoán các bạn đưa ra nó sẽ không
chắc chắn nữa. Thì bây giờ người ta sẽ
cần có một cái tiêu chí nào để người ta
đánh giá được cái sự lệch của cái kết
quả này? Càng lệch thì càng tốt đúng
không? Ví dụ như này, nếu mình chọn là
đi, mình chọn là đi. Thì trong số 14
người đã từng đến vay tiền thì có năm
người trẻ, bốn người trung tuổi, bốn
người trung niên và năm người là già
đúng không? Thì trong năm người trẻ tôi
đã từng cho hai người vay và ba người
không cho vay. Nên là trong tương lai
nếu có một ông nào ông đấy trẻ ông này
đến tôi sẽ không cho vay đúng không?
Trong quá khứ đã có bốn ông trung niên
đến, cả bốn ông nữa đều cho vay đi ạ.
Ông nào đến mới đi thì tôi cũng sẽ cho
vay luôn. Nó lệch như này cơ mà đúng
không? Senior cũng thế. Trong năm ông đã
từng đến, tôi cho ông ba ông cho vay và
hai ông tôi không cho vay. Nên là trong
tương lai nếu có ông nào senor đến tôi
lại cho vay tiếp đúng không? Nhưng rõ
ràng cái nhánh ở giữa này là cái nhánh
tôi chắc chắn hơn đúng không? Cái quyết
định tôi nó sẽ đáng tin cậy hơn tại vì
nó lệch đúng không? Thì bây giờ tôi phải
có một cái magic để tôi đánh giá được
cái sự lệch này. Tức là khi tôi chọn cái
này thì bao này nó lệch đến mức nào? Khi
tôi chọn cái income thì ba này lệch đến
mức nào? Khi tôi chọn cái student hai
ông này lệch đến mức nào? Và khi tôi
chọn credit thì hai ông này nó lệch đến
mức nào? Đúng không? Ông nào mà tạo ra
càng nhiều giá trị lệch thì càng tốt.
Ông nào mà tạo ra càng nhiều giá trị đều
thì càng tồi. Thì đấy chính là cái tiêu
chí người ta dùng để người ta chọn xem
là cái feature nào nó là root note và cả
những cái decision note nữa đúng không?
Ờ sau khi có root xong các bạn cũng phải
chọn tiếp những cái dưới mà đúng không?
Thì tất cả đều là đúng không? Tất cả cái
nố này đều là decion note. Chẳng qua cái
ông đầu tiên thì là root và cái ông đầu
đầu tiên thôi. Còn những cái ông sau,
những cái nốt sau ấy bản thân chúng cũng
là cái nốt gốc của những cái cây con
đúng không? Ông bằng giỏi này là nốt gốc
của cây con này thì ông có kinh nghiệm
là nốt gốc của cây con này. Tức là cái
nốt nào cũng là nốt gốc của một cây nào
đấy. Chẳng qua cái nút nốt là cái nốt
gốc của cả cây to tướng ở ngoài cùng
thôi đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ cái chỉ
số nào cái magic nào tôi đánh giá bây
giờ thì tôi sẽ có một cái magic.
Tôi có rất nhiều magic khác nhau nhưng
mà trong đó có m ch magic rất là phổ
biến người ta gọi là gini index. Cái
công thức của gini index đây các bạn
nhá. C ở đây là số lượng class. Trong
trường hợp này chúng ta chỉ có hai class
là yes với no thôi. Mình sẽ gọi là class
số 1, class số 2. Được chưa? Nó bằng gì?
Ghi nó bằng 1 trừ đi tổng sigma của y
chạy từ 1 cho đến c của P bình phương. P
là cái gì? Pi là xác suất để
xác suất của cái class số y. Đây ví dụ
nhá các bạn nhìn này. Ví dụ đây. Ví dụ
nhá. Cái trường hợp này đi. Cái H này đi
cho công thức nhá. Đúng không? C là bằng
2. Tại vì là các bạn chỉ có hai class và
yes với no thôi. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ
pi là cái gì? Các bạn nhìn này. Ông đầu
tiên nhá. Ông đầu tiên này cái nhánh đầu
tiên nhá. Nhánh đầu cái nhánh đầu tiên
này mình sẽ tính ghi gini cho từng cái
nhánh một nhá. Đúng không? Cái âm đầu
tiên các bạn có hai class yes với no
đúng không? Yes là bằng 2. No là bằng 3.
Thì bây giờ yes là class số 1, no là
class số 2 đúng không? Thì P1 bằng gì?
P1 bằng 2 chia 5. 2 chia 5 là bằng 0,4.
Còn P2 là bằng 3 chia 5 là bằng 0,6. Thì
bây gi các bạn tính g bằng gì? Bằng 1
trừ đi tổng của 0,4 bình cộng 0,6 bình
thì bằng 0,48. 0,48 được chưa? 0,48
tương tự như vậy hôm nay cũng thế thôi.
Yes no này đúng không? Ờ yes là bằng 4
đâu bằng 0. Thì bây giờ P1 là bằng 4
chia 4 là bằng 1. Còn P0 là bằng 0 chia
4 là bằng 0. Thì bây giờ gini bằng 1 trừ
đi 1 bình cộng 0 bình nó bằng 0. Được
chưa? Và tương tự như vậy cái chỉ số này
ấ cái chỉ số này ấ nó càng bé thì càng
tốt. Đây bé nhất là bằng 0. Bé nhất là
bằng 0 là tốt nhất.
Còn nó càng lớn thì càng tồi. Và lớn
nhất bằng 0,5. Nó sẽ bằng 0,5 khi nào?
Trường hợp tồn nhất nó bằng 0,5 khi nào
các bạn? Nếu mà hai ông này làm sao nó
bằng nhau đúng không? 22 hoặc là 33 hoặc
44 không? Hai này bằng nhau thì lập tức
là mỗi ông đều bằng 0,5. 0,5 bình phương
bằng 0,0,25. 1 trừ đi 0,25 bình cộng 0,5
bình thì bằng đúng 0,5 đúng không? Cái
gini này ấy nó càng lớn càng hơn 0,5 thì
càng tồi. Càng hơn 0 thì càng tốt đúng
không? Thì đây cái gini của cái nhánh
trẻ tuổi là 0,48 là tồi rồi đúng không?
Ghi của nhánh trung tuổi là 0 là tốt.
Ghi nhìn của nhánh lớn tuổi là bằng 0,48
là thì cũng tương đối tồi đúng không?
Thì bây giờ muốn tính khi chung cho cái
S này thì tôi sẽ tính trung bình có
trọng số thôi đúng không? 5 sample 4
sample 5 sle nó bằng gì? 5/14 nh 0,48
đúng không? Chúng mình có chọn có số này
5/14 nh 0,48 cộng với 4/14 nhân với 0
cộng với 5/14 nh 0,48 bằng 0,343. Thì
đây chính là cái gini index của cái h
này. Và mình cũng sẽ tính tương tự cho
những ông còn lại đúng không? Mình tính
tương tự còn lại tức là gì? Ông nào tôi
cũng tính thế này đúng không? Ông nào
tôi cũng sẽ tính thế này đúng không? Rồi
đến cuối tôi sẽ xem là ông nào là ông bé
nhất được chưa? Ông nào là ông bé nhất
thì tôi sẽ chọn ông đấy là cái nút gốc
được chưa? Ông nào là ông có cái gin bé
nhất cái s là 0,343 mấy cái kia nó sẽ
bao nhiêu đấy đúng không? Thì ông nào bé
nhất thì tôi sẽ chọn ông đấy là cái nốt
gốc.
Sau khi tôi chọn nốt gốc rồi thì các bạn
nhìn nhá. Ví v ví dụ ví dụ ở đây ví dụ ở
đây cái nốt này đi. Ví dụ này nó là cái
nốt mà có cái gini tốt nhất đi. Đúng
không? Ví dụ như vậy đi. Thì bây giờ
nhưng mà cái cây của tôi thường nó sẽ
không phải nó chỉ có một một level như
này nó sẽ có nhiều level. Thế bây giờ
những cái level sau ta làm thế nào? Thì
bây giờ phải xét xem là ông nào cần phải
phát triển tiếp. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Giống kiểu này này đây đúng không? Có
những cái nhánh các bạn lại phải phát
triển nhiều. Có những cái nhánh các bạn
lại phát triển ít đúng không? Thì bây
giờ tôi đặt câu hỏi là gì? là ông nào là
ông mà tôi sẽ phải phát triển nhiều.
Được chưa? Thì rất là đơn giản thôi các
bạn nhìn đây đúng không? Bây giờ ví dụ
đi tôi chọn cái s là nốt là là nốt gốc
đúng không? Tôi có ba nhánh là Young,
Midder với cả Senior. Rồi thì cái nhánh
Mid ấy nó đã đủ lệch rồi đúng không? Nó
4 triệu đúng không? 40 rất là lệch rồi.
Thì ở đây tôi thể tôi sẽ đưa ra dự đoán
luôn là gì? Trong tương lai mà ông nào
ông ấy đến mà trung tuổi phát là tôi cho
vay luôn. Tại vì là
tất cả những âm trong quá khứ tôi đều
cho vay rồi. Còn hai cái nhánh là trẻ
tuổi với cả lớn tuổi ấy, hai nhánh này
nó chưa lệch lắm thì bây giờ sẽ phân
chia tiếp đúng không? Phân chia tiếp tôi
lại gì? Tôi lại ngồi tính tiếp. Tôi lại
ngồi tính gini in cho age, cho income,
cho student, cho credit xem là xem là
ông nào nên là cái nốp tiếp theo đúng
không? Tôi lại cứ phân chia tiếp như vậy
đúng không? Đến bao giờ? đến bao giờ khi
nào nó có rất nhiều tiêu chí để tôi có
thể tôi dừng phát triển được cây này.
Một là lúc ban đầu tôi định nghĩa là cây
tôi chỉ sâu tối đa là hai hoặc là ba
level thôi. Thì nếu mà đến cái maximum
rồi thì tôi sẽ dừng. Hoặc là gì? Nếu mà
tôi thấy là khi mà cái nốt tôi nó lệch
rồi đây 40 hoặc là 30 nhả tôi đủ lệch
rồi thì tôi sẽ dừng. Hoặc là nếu mà cái
nốt lá này nó nốt này nó có ít hơn n
phần tử, ví dụ ít hơn hai phần tử tôi sẽ
không chia nữa đúng không? Thì đấy là
cách để chúng ta có thể phát triển đến
cây này. Thấy chưa? Một là tôi dựa vào
độ dài thôi, tôi đ nghĩa là maximum tôi
chỉ có ba level thôi. Hết ba level là
tôi dừng đúng không? Lệch hay không tôi
cũng dừng. Được chưa? Lệch hay không tôi
cũng dừng tôi dùng đa số. Hai là tôi yêu
cầu là tôi sẽ phát triển đến khi nào mà
nó phải lệch đến mức tỉ lệ nào đấy hoặc
là đến khi nào mà nốt lá của tôi tôi có
ít hơn 10 phần tử. Ví dụ như vậy là tôi
dừng đúng không? Thì đấy là cách để
người ta có thể phát triển decision tre
được chưa? Decree
dựa trên cây đúng không các bạn? Các bạn
học môn cấu trúc duệu và giải thuật đấy.
Các bạn đã từng học cây rồi đúng không?
Đấy cây như này này. Chưa.
Trong machining đây được xếp vào một
thật toán yếu. Yếu tức là gì? Tức là
thường dự đoán nó độ chính xác nó không
cao nhá. Yếu có nghĩa là độ chính xác nó
không cao. Được chưa? Đây người ta gọi
là weak model, một mô hình yếu.
Thông thường trong machining người ta sẽ
không dùng decision tre đơn lẻ.
Người ta sẽ không dùng dec lẻ mà ta
thường ta sẽ kết hợp giữa nhiều disin
với nhau.
Kết hợp như nào thì mai chúng ta nói
tiếp nhá. Nào các bạn trong nội dung hôm
nay có bạn học câu hỏi gì không?
Nội dung cho đến phần này có ai có thắc
mắc gì không? Nội dung này là hết rồi.
Bây giờ có Q&A thôi, chỉ có hỏi và trả
lời thôi.
Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Ô không ai hỏi gì à?
Thế hôm nay về cái về cái thử nghĩ xem
là có cái gì các bạn. Thắm mắc mình nghĩ
là sẽ phải có cái các bạn các bạn các
bạn chưa clear chứ nhở. Làm sao mà cả
lớp hiểu hết thế này được đúng không?
Thì nếu mà các bạn có cái gì các bạn
chưa clear thì các bạn nhắn tin mình
trên Zalo mai các bạn hỏi nhá.
Mình không nghĩ là tuận này một phát đã
hiểu được ngay đâu các bạn nhá. Được
chưa? Mai chúng ta sẽ học tiếp. Hôm nay
chúng ta đã học được khoảng nửa non toán
rồi. Mai chúng ta sẽ học tiếp về nửa già
tôi toán còn lại nhá.
Ok. Thế nhá. Mai vẫn giờ này các bạn
nhá. Được chưa?
Ok. Chúc mọi người ăn tối ngon miệng
nha. Mai vẫn giờ này nhá.
>> Dạ em cảm ơn thầy ạ.
>> Ok bye mọi người nha. Bye mọi người nha.
Bye mọi người nha.
M.